Hello everybody!
Oh my god it's so weird!
Oh, our very first stream with our new skin suit, guys.
Oh, it feels a little bit weird to be honest.
I was trying to figure out how big should I be on the screen.
I don't know.
I was trying to figure it out.
Alright, so we have a lot of updates and stuff.
I know the intro is still not updated yet.
It's actually done.
But I am trying to figure out what color background to use.
So it's either going to be a different background or it's going to be a different color.
It's going to be the same.
But it is done.
And I basically hibernated for 24 hours after the debut.
I was just... I was gone.
I can't...
After the... after the like, uh, re-debut, I was out.
I was actually like brain dead.
Like I couldn't.
I was so tired.
I like woke up from my sleep and I was so mentally just drained.
Because all the stress.
And like all the preparations that kept inside.
It was like, it's over.
And then like it all cop up to me.
And I'm like, this would be how I felt if I didn't hold it in.
I was just... I was like talking to my staff team today.
I was talking to my... like we had a meeting.
And then I was like, I'm so tired.
They were like, you're so tired.
I was like, I'm so tired.
They were like, alright, we gotta do this.
We gotta do that.
And they're like, are you okay, doki?
And I'm like, I'm so tired.
So I was just like, okay, I'm...
I can't... I need a... I need... I need a rest.
I'm... I know everybody's watching me because the debut was so successful.
But I need a sleep.
I... I need to slow down now.
I'm tired.
But I... I...
I really, really, really wanted to try out the early access.
The early access for the newest big update for PAL World.
Was it called the Sakura Gima...
The Sakura Gima update.
Because Hiro messaged me and was like, Hey, I have early access.
I have a... I have early access.
Do you want to check it out?
Do you want to stream it?
And I was like, oh my god.
You know, because like, she has early access for two days.
So I was just like, okay, doki.
I know today you promised behind the scenes.
But then, but early access is the only time to be like, I have early access and you don't.
No, doki.
I want to be like, alright, I want to show you guys.
The early access for the new PAL.
Because I know, I know some of you guys would be like, PAL World.
Oh my god.
We watched so much PAL World.
But no, this is different.
This is new content.
This is new content PAL World.
So there's things you've never seen before this time.
So it's...
And I never got to stream PAL World for you guys.
I never.
Yeah, you might have watched a hundred thousand other people play PAL World.
But you never watch doki play PAL World.
And I, compared to the other people that played PAL World, they don't have early access like me.
So you have to watch this stream.
But yes, I...
Oh, yeah, sorry.
I forgot about Twitch.
Yeah, but you know, some YouTubers, YouTube people don't watch Twitch and they don't know the existence.
But I do.
And I also forgot about my Twitch VOD channel.
So Madrid, a lot of people, a lot of Dragos did not watch me play PAL World.
And this is PAL World on my YouTube channel that you weren't able to...
Yeah, it's a tournament chat.
It was different.
Stakes were high.
Tensions were high.
People were yelling at each other.
Now instead I'm just gonna yell at you instead.
Instead!
Yeah, but it was a clip compilation!
That is different!
A clip compilation is not a real thing!
Because there's no social interaction by being live on chat!
I'm sorry for the vodwatchers, but we can pretend I'm live for you if you're vodwatching right now.
We can pretend that we're live together if you're vodwatching right now.
Anyway!
As I was saying...
So, I really wanted to stream the early access because in two days, it wouldn't be early access.
So that's why I was like, okay, I gotta stream early access before everybody has access to it.
Other than that, I'm definitely gonna take it much more chill.
I know I still have three streams for the week.
This one, and then Chain Together with RPR and Ditto.
Which might be a very terrible idea.
Because I don't know how bad the ping's gonna be.
What server we're gonna be playing Chain Together.
And we have to be in sync while everybody has...
while one of us is gonna have 200 ping.
So...
I don't know how it's gonna go when, you know, one of us is gonna go in with 200 to 300 ping playing a game that requires synchronization of jumps.
So, we're gonna be like 3, 2, 1, jump.
One of us has to jump at 2.
So, this might have been a little bit of a very terrible idea.
Umm...
When it's already a rage baiting game.
And then we have the behind the scenes.
I know I said I was gonna put it earlier.
But like I said, a lot of things moved around.
And it lets the team have a chance to put together all the things they want me to talk about during the behind the scenes.
But yes, shout out to the project team.
Umm... we had a little celebration right after.
Umm... it was a great pleasure working with everybody there.
And we are actually gonna upload a director's cut of the whole debut video.
We're gonna have a director's cut.
Cause there was some cut content.
A little bit of cut content in there.
And we wanna like brush it up a lot more.
So, you get like deleted content and also the adjusting the sound, balancing, adding more sound effects and everything.
Fixing it all up.
Tidying it all up.
So, a director's cut will be will be uploaded in the future.
Umm...
Anyway, Blade, thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
Clip, clip, clip!
Out of context!
Thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh my god, I'm so bouncy.
Now you guys can actually see me actually I actually move around a lot when I talk.
But you guys never really see that.
I'm so self conscious cause now you actually see me.
I'm like a very... I like to... if you guys see like my hand tracking too, I actually talk with my hands as well.
So like...
I'm so bouncy.
Oh my gosh.
It's weird.
I've never... I've never like...
I'm not used to having you guys see how bouncy I actually am when I'm when I'm talking.
Umm... It's a... It's a...
unique experience for sure.
Okay, I have to tell you guys a funny story.
So like... I...
I thought that...
Umm... For Pal World when they said New World Also, Lima thank you for the 50 gifted chips!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much!
Umm...
But when they said...
It's like New World I legitimately thought like we were gonna be transported into like an entire new map.
But no.
It adds on to the map.
And then so... Umm...
So...
Very funny story.
I was very confused.
Cause I was like...
Oh Hiro... Umm...
Where is this place?
And they were like...
Oh just run north west and you'll get there.
So I was like...
Oh okay.
So the thing is...
I'm starting a whole new world because I never...
I... Umm...
I...
I didn't have a world yet.
So the thing is...
I started a whole new world.
And...
Umm...
I got in.
I was like... I wanted to see if I could find it.
Before I start the stream.
So at least we can...
We hadn't cut the time of me finding it on stream.
So I was like...
I had level 1 trying to fucking run to find this new area.
And then I had to swim.
Because she was like...
North West.
Little do I know...
It was not just North West.
And...
I will give you like...
An illustrated...
Like... I was like... Hiro...
Can you like... Circle it on the map?
What do you mean...
North West?
And then...
She sent me...
She sent me the map.
I was like...
I was never gonna make it.
By just running.
I looked at it and I was like...
I was never...
What do you mean...
Just run...
North West?
What do you...
I know how to get there though.
I know...
How to get there.
Alright we are gonna name a new world.
Let's do Dragoon Islands.
We will do Dragoon Islands.
And...
And then...
We have to turn multiplayer on.
And we will do...
I think that is fine.
I don't really care about like...
I mean we can make the night time faster.
You know what?
We will make it...
Fifteen...
Alright...
And then...
There is a reason!
There is a...
There is a reason...
No no guys.
Okay.
There is a reason.
Okay we don't need that much...
Night time.
Like what are we gonna do at night?
There is a reason!
No you have...
No there is a reason.
I will show you guys why.
Why?
Okay give me a...
Guys there is a reason.
You know...
Fifteen to twenty you are right.
Let's just get a good middle ground.
Guys...
Let me give you...
Guys I have a reason why I did this.
There is...
No I swear to God.
I swear to God.
There is a reason why guys.
I swear.
And I will show you why.
When I am in.
Um...
I figured out why.
Alright.
Let's do a classic.
Okay.
Uh...
And then...
What was it?
Oh yeah there we go.
There we go.
Bringing back...
Twitch rivals Doki.
I think I was like this face right?
Or was it...
Oh no.
It was this one.
And then it was...
Which pupil was it?
It was... I think it was a normal pupil.
We have more of a teal color.
Uh...
Maybe like...
Was it this?
Is that my eye color now?
I don't remember.
It was like this.
Yeah there you go.
That's my eye color now.
And then blonde...
Oh God.
I am so bad with colors.
There we go.
So you know it's all natural.
I didn't dye my hair.
So you know...
It's all natural.
There was no hair color dye.
Oh this is harder.
Cause like there's no actual like...
My hairstyle this time around.
So it is a little more difficult.
Cause I'm like which ones...
Which one... Is this my hairstyle?
I guess.
Or is it this?
Is this my hairstyle?
I guess.
Right?
I feel like this is much more of my hairstyle.
I wish I could just copy the color that I...
Uh... That I put in there.
Okay there you go.
And it has like less like that.
Yeah I think that's good.
I think...
I think that's good.
Huh.
Alright.
Yeah let's just go with average.
Okay there we go.
Uh... Oh shit.
Real female doki.
I think I was just doki bird.
I think.
Okay.
Uh... Maybe I should do...
Real female doki.
There you go.
So you guys will know.
You know it's me.
Alright.
I'll show you guys why.
Eating all those crabby patties.
Okay we all don't even see the intro.
We've seen this intro like...
10 million different times.
Okay so...
Guys.
I... Okay so...
This is...
This is where we're at.
Right?
So...
This is where we're at.
Okay?
So...
And then...
My friend...
She...
She licked me the mat.
And it's all the way on the top left.
Do you want to know where we are?
I'll show you where we are.
On the map guys.
For those who are like... But where are we doki?
Where are we you say?
We are here.
That's where we are.
So I was like...
And then...
And the hero was like...
Run north west.
That was...
That was my instructions.
So I was like...
Okay.
And then I was like...
I can't find it.
And the hero was like...
Oh don't worry I got the map.
It's here.
It's...
I just thought it was so funny.
And the hero was like...
Oh yeah by the way you have to die and respawn.
You have to...
You have to respawn.
But I didn't know.
I...
I should have asked for more instructions.
Oh my god.
I didn't know.
So the plan is...
Is that we have to die.
And then...
We...
After we die...
We go to top left.
We go here.
This is where we are guys.
We...
Have to respawn...
Here.
And then...
After you respawn...
You see that?
That's the place.
Over there.
There it is.
That's our new place.
That we have to go.
It's all the way over there.
Okay.
Up the volume a little bit too.
Whoops sorry I almost doxxed you.
Sound guy.
The openness secret.
Alright.
It could be anybody.
It could be anybody guys.
It could be anybody chat.
Oh it's so clear.
I don't think they know this guys.
Sound guy.
I don't think they know this sound guy.
It could be anybody.
Anybody's name starts with A.
You know?
Alright.
Alright here we go.
Guys I need to heal up a little bit before I start swimming.
I know I have these muscular legs.
But like...
I died one time.
Trying to swim all the way there.
I need to like...
Self heal a little bit.
Alright here we go.
Okay I realize that my endurance is...
Okay I almost forgot.
We have to go up here.
We have to go...
All the way up here.
And then...
Jump over here.
And then swim.
And then...
We swim.
Yeah his name is Audio Guy.
Chat.
Alright there we go.
That's how you go to Sakura Jima.
Mushroom area.
That's how you get there.
See there's a reason why I have to wait until I like...
Like had like...
Regen my HP because I already lost my stamina.
And there you go!
I got a mushroom and I leveled up!
Yay!
Alright let me...
Push up the audio a little bit more.
I think there's like a...
I push up the audio too.
Alright nice.
Okay so I'm pretty sure you can...
Edit the sound.
I haven't...
Right?
Yeah.
Is there anything we need to edit?
Uh...
Audio... whoops.
Wait.
What did I press?
Why are my eyes sparkling?
What?
I don't even know what...
I don't even know what I pressed.
Okay I need to make sure...
Oh shit okay.
Okay we definitely don't need...
Okay guys I did not look at my settings.
I did not...
Okay no camera shake.
I don't know if you guys noticed but I...
I did not look at my settings at all.
Alright here we go.
And then game settings, toggle, sprint, on, off.
Okay.
Let's get the sensitivity...
A little bit low.
And we should be...
Good.
Alright bring down...
Bring the ambient sound...
Down a little bit.
Alright uh...
Ambient.
I'll put it at 70 and I'll...
Bring this up.
Alright let me know if it's better.
Alright.
Okay.
Let me fix my...
Thing.
How do I... Oh my gosh.
How do I um...
Oh that's my clip.
Guys I don't remember anything.
That's my glasses.
Oh no.
Give me a sec.
I don't remember anything.
Those...
Those are my glasses.
I don't need to wear my glasses.
Okay I set it all up.
On a little...
On a little device.
Guys I'm still learning guys.
I'm not used to having so many things.
It's... It's weird.
It's so weird.
Alright.
There we go.
Now I have my eyes again.
Alright.
I have... Alright.
And now we're here!
Look!
And this is the reason why I had to level up.
I need to level up really fast.
They're level 45.
This is a... This...
Area...
This...
It's... It's a...
They're very high level.
So what happened was that I was minding my own business.
Exploring the area.
Cause I was like oh okay.
I should like figure this out.
You know?
I was like oh I should like...
I should know what's going on before like know how to get here.
You know like find the first...
Find the first area that has like the checkpoint.
The...
That has...
We're friends right?
Yeah they're little pussy.
They're little bitches too.
So you don't have to worry about these guys.
They're...
They're very afraid of you.
But I bumped into a clan of enemies that were not afraid of me.
And um...
And I was like oh they're pretty cute.
Look at those frogs!
And then I looked at these frogs and they turned around and beat my ass.
It literally took one hit and I was gone.
So for those who are gonna go to Sakurajima, do not get near the frogs.
Do not get near the frogs.
The frogs will kill you.
So be careful of the frogs.
They will absolutely kill you.
Literally one hit me and I was gone.
I got jumped on by the frog mafia.
I was like, oh cute, there's those frogs!
And then there I go.
I was gone.
I wish I still had my old world.
.
Oh yeah, and apparently, if I knew, I would have brought my old world into the beta.
So at least I think I was like level 30 in my old world.
So yeah, we're starting back at zero.
And that is why!
That is...
No I can't.
It's gone forever.
That is why we had to set up the XP leveling up thing.
Okay.
Look at him.
Look he's such a...
Oh!
Okay, I didn't think he'd actually chase me.
No please.
Someone in my chat said to hit you and I thought it would be funny!
Okay, we're fine.
We're okay.
Yeah, do not hit a level 46 dinosaur despite what your...
What your inner thoughts are telling you.
What your intrusive thoughts say.
Do not...
Do not try to beat up a...
Level 46.
.
I'm trying to find the first checkpoint!
It's like somewhere here.
I found it before!
It was like...
Here.
Okay, there's a lot.
There's a lot going on.
Oh, but I found an effigy though.
Let's go!
Ah...
Alright.
Here we go.
Where?
Where do we go?
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
The first... the first checkpoint!
The first checkpoint.
Ah...
Alright.
It's fine.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
There's apparently a lot of new pals as well.
And there's like...
There's like treasure...
There's like an oil rig.
And you can actually get oil now.
And there's like oil strongholds and everything.
And then there's like...
These are the frogs over there.
Whatever they're not called.
The Krojiro.
Be careful of the Krojiro.
They are not friendly.
If you're like even like 5 centimeters...
See?
Look!
Oh shit!
.
They just... they don't care.
I just wanted to be friendly.
Look, I leveled up though.
I'm level 4 now.
I'm just a baby.
I didn't realize... okay, that was a little bit of my fault because I didn't realize...
I didn't realize the range of that fucking attack.
I'm gonna get my shit back though.
I need to get to the checkpoint over there before anything happens.
I need to get to the checkpoint.
I need to at least claim the checkpoint.
That's all I want.
Please, I just... I just want only 41 more levels to go.
I just wanted to claim the checkpoint.
That's really it.
I just wanted to claim it.
Oh my god.
Okay, don't worry.
It's gonna be fine.
I just wanted to explore.
Oh no, it's getting dark.
I don't know what type of pals show up in the dark.
But there's apparently like a... a new type of...
A new type of currency.
Where... look at them run.
That's right.
Run.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
That's right.
Yeah.
Yeah, you're afraid of me?
Oh no.
These fucking... I trained very hard to get these legs.
No, there's a new form of PAL that's... Oh my god.
Oh my god.
I tied so far.
There's a... Oh my god.
Fuck this though.
Let me put these... Okay.
Alright.
There's a new form of PALS that holds currency.
That you have to capture or kill.
I'm not sure.
But I was reading up on like... the... the new stuff.
So like to see if I can get there.
Um...
And basically it's like...
It's so weird.
It's like... it's called DogCoin.
I think they were trying to make a parody of DogeCoin.
And it... Oh, rest in peace by the way.
I don't know if you guys know this but like...
The... the... the...
Doge finally passed away.
After 20 plus years.
And I'm... Oh my god.
Like...
I was like... I was just like...
Rest in peace cause...
Cause like... He was... She was like blind death.
And had to wear diapers.
And I was just like... Oh my god.
Like I was just like...
Oh my god.
She can finally be at peace.
Like... Anyway.
Um...
She was really...
Really old.
Also... I am... I don't know where to go.
Uh...
Oh no.
Okay.
Uh... Anyway.
Uh... I was surprised.
I didn't realize...
No.
I can't see.
I...
Yeah.
She was very well loved.
She was kept...
I was so surprised finding out.
Guys.
I fucked up.
I... I don't know where I...
I...
I don't know.
Oh no.
I so...
This is bad.
Okay.
Do I have a torch?
Do I have a...
Where am I?
It's just the swamp.
It's only the swamp.
I need a go to.
Oh it's over here.
I see the blue light.
I see my items.
Anyway.
Uh... They... They did like dog coin.
In this game.
And... Um...
And...
And like a pair... It's like a form of currency.
Where you can buy...
Palskins.
Uh... And I don't remember.
I don't really remember much about it.
It was like...
You can buy Palskins and...
Uh...
Okay.
I need like a...
Oh no.
I hear the frog.
He's angry.
The frog's angry.
Please leave me alone.
I just... I just want to...
Get my items back.
Leave me alone.
Yeah.
But there's no poison though.
So that's good.
Oh thank god.
He's sleeping.
Oh shit.
What the fuck is that?
Oh I don't want to look back to see I'm level one.
I'm level five.
Well I don't know why I paused there.
I should not be turning around.
Just to see what they are.
Dude fuck those frogs though.
I hate these frogs.
All my homies hate those frogs.
Alright and...
Is that my items?
Is that it?
Oh thank god.
At least you don't get...
Poisoned.
I'm so happy.
Thank fucking god there's no...
Oh!
Are they friendly?
Hello?
Oh no.
Oh okay.
He's running.
Oh shit!
Guess they're not friendly.
My...
I'm cold.
I'm starving.
And I'm dying.
I'm dying.
I just wanted to say hi.
I don't understand.
The green ones were friendly.
The...
Why was this one not friendly?
I'm gonna take my anger out on you.
Ugh.
That's fucking right.
I'm gonna take my anger off of you.
I get bullied.
So you get bullied.
It's a fucking cycle.
Where are you trying to go?
That's right.
I'm not breaking the cycle.
Alright.
Nice.
I'm still cold.
So I'm gonna get Mooch off this guy's fire.
To be less cold.
Break the cycle.
That's too late.
I'm not breaking any cycles today.
The cycle continues.
Alright.
We got a...
Okay.
We definitely gotta get that.
And then we gotta get...
Palace sphere.
Repair bench.
This.
We need a bed.
We need this.
Do we need a repair kit?
No, we don't.
We need cloth.
We need shield.
Feed box.
Hang.
No, we don't need that.
Berries.
We don't need any of those.
I guess we need none of that.
Yeah.
Violence.
Bring violence.
Alright.
Check the survival guide.
I did it.
I don't wanna live here.
That's the thing.
I just wanna get my items.
That's all I want.
I just...
I don't wanna... I just wanna get to the checkpoint.
It's literally right there.
The checkpoint is like...
Like next to the...
My body.
My dead body.
I swear.
I've seen it.
Um...
Gino, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're right, Doki.
This is a unique Power World stream.
Well worth watching.
Do I even have enough for a torch?
Oh my god.
Oh, tab.
That's why.
I know I'm doing sparkles.
Oooh.
It's cause tab is my sparkle.
Hahaha.
Now I know.
Every time I...
I'm like, it's time to upgrade.
Oh.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
It's upgrade time.
Hahaha.
Guys, why is it still so dark in Cod?
I don't understand.
Why is it so dark in cold, sir?
Hahaha.
I said I wanted shorter night time.
How is night time so long?
Did I fuck up?
Hahaha.
Did I accidentally make night twice?
I thought shorter means shorter night time.
Oh my god.
I said it backwards.
Okay, guys.
I made a mistake.
I'm sorry.
Guys.
I...
Okay, guys.
I made a mistake.
We gotta fix this.
I didn't realize I actually made it longer.
I thought I had made it shorter.
I was so confused.
Alright.
There we go.
That's better.
Oh, so this is the opposite.
Oh.
Okay.
Things make a lot more sense now.
So does this mean...
I think we can be at like 18.
A solid 18 now.
And then that's it.
Alright.
We figured it out.
It's...
Yeah.
Sorry.
I'm a little special.
Hahaha.
New skin suit.
Same old doki.
So that's when you know like...
Things are...
Things never change.
Hahaha.
Alright.
How fast is this then?
Is it gonna be daytime soon, sir?
Do you think the sun's gonna be...
gonna come out now?
Because...
Wait.
It's getting brighter.
I can see!
Wait.
I can see now!
Guys.
Does that mean I can make it?
I think I can make it, guys.
I think I can make it.
Okay.
I need to figure out how to get there.
I need to figure out how to get above.
Oh!
I can see now!
I can see!
It is getting brighter!
Okay.
Alright.
This is it.
Guys.
This is our mission.
Our mission...
Our mission.
It's...
We gotta get my stuff.
Get a checkpoint.
Head back to the old... the place we...
Our new home over there.
Get to at least level 15.
And then...
Maybe I don't get one shot.
Like... That's our goal.
Hahaha.
Maybe...
Maybe by then...
By then things will be okay.
Things will be okay.
Third time's a charm, guys.
Third time's a charm.
We can make it.
I believe.
Days are... nights are shorter now.
Our goal...
Kill a frog.
Hahaha.
That's...
That's our goal.
Wait.
No chat on screen?
Oh no.
Okay.
I'll fix that later.
First off, we need to figure out how to...
Guys, first off, we have to figure out a lot of things first.
Okay.
One at a time.
Guys, one...
We have to do things one at a time.
Hahaha.
There's... There's a lot of stuff going on.
Alright.
One at... Look, I gotta compensate.
Okay.
If I...
Hahaha.
If I... If I don't have the front, at least I have the back.
Okay?
All my assets are...
All my assets are up in the...
Hahaha.
That's where all the assets are.
Alright.
Oh, I see it.
I see the two bright blue lights.
Um...
It's right there.
I see it.
We're gonna make it.
Alright.
Oh, I want the effigy though.
Yay!
Alright.
We got the effigy right here.
And...
And then we gotta get out of there.
And then...
Oh my god.
I haven't played Palworld in so long.
I remember just...
I don't remember what level.
I think I...
I think I stopped at level 30.
Uh, like just playing it.
Just playing it like not in a tournament setting.
Oh my god.
Guys.
I swear guys.
It'll be so cool.
The moment we can make it.
The moment we make it here.
I swear.
This place will be so cool.
When I don't insta-die, you guys are gonna see how cool this place is.
I swear guys.
I'm not coping.
The moment...
Oh no.
I'm sorry.
Don't look at me.
Oh no.
Oh, okay.
We're fine.
He didn't see me guys.
He's afraid of the water.
It's okay.
When the power will become a horror game guys.
That's the lonely level five trying to figure out her place in this world.
Alright.
We're okay.
We gotta head.
We gotta head over here.
That's our stuff.
That's our stuff over there.
That's where I died chat.
Oh no.
No, it's streamers.
Streamers don't hurt you.
Streamers are the ones that are afraid of you.
So we're fine chat.
These guys don't hurt you.
See look.
They're running away.
Look at that.
They don't know.
They're level 46 but they don't know.
They think I'm just as big of a threat as the others.
Wait.
There's a key?
When did I get a key?
When the fuck did I get a key?
Alright.
They're just funny little guys.
They don't know what to expect.
They think I'm a threat.
I mean if I saw those thighs I'd run away too.
Is that a free powball?
Um.
Mason thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you.
Dragoons I'm trying to sneak around but I'm dummy thick and the clap from my ass cheeks keeps alerting the frogs.
What are you?
Oh god it's the frogs.
It's the frogs.
Oh god.
Oh no.
I was too dummy thick.
I can't believe it.
Okay.
On cue I alerted them.
Oh that's so cute.
Wait.
Isn't that different skin?
That's not the usual one.
Yeah.
He's green now.
Cause it used to be like full white.
Yeah there's like the white version up ahead too.
Alright we gotta get this though.
Yeah.
See dog coin.
See I told you.
Dog coin is real.
Hahaha.
I told you they're real.
Alright.
So there's the green version of these guys.
See.
Look at him.
They're so cute.
Is he friendly?
Hello.
Yeah he's friendly.
Okay.
Thank god.
I forgot they're friendly or not.
So we have like these guys and then and then like these things over here that's the oil area I believe.
So like uh what if I just live here?
Like this place seems peaceful and there's like rocks everywhere too.
And then there's Lulu which is like uh.
Like see they're not afraid of me and there's an oil rig here.
Like what if I just live here?
Hahaha.
Like this is a place where you drill for oil.
And there's like rocks here that I can use for mining.
And then there's some trees.
Like yeah like everybody around me is like super fucking strong.
But like I'll have oil.
Is that all we wanted?
But I'll have oil though.
And like oil's nice.
I like oil.
Oh yeah this is it.
See.
Oh.
Oh nice.
I got a gold coin.
When did I get a gold coin?
I don't even remember that.
Alright so this is the new place.
Um I am really too weak for this new place.
There's some new pals over there.
The copyright free scythers over there.
Hahaha.
Those are the legally distinct purple scythers.
Oh shit what did the sound guy say?
Um.
Okay.
So I did not remember.
Hahaha.
Wait how many times did it sound?
Four times.
Oops.
Okay.
Uh give me uh to 80 of 5.
Uh let's see and then here you go.
Alright let me know.
Alright there you go.
There is uh there is that.
And then oh wait who are these guys?
Who are these guys?
Are these guys the rebels?
Who are they?
I've never seen them before.
Who are these guys?
The moonflower John.
Who are you guys?
I know you're not friendly.
AHHHHH!
Hahaha.
Okay.
Okay now.
There's Samura.
Hahaha.
Guys I can't.
I need to stop looking.
Oh my god they're so fast.
But they can't climb.
They're so stupid.
They can't.
Oh my god they're so fucking Holy shit!
What the fuck!
Why are they so fast?
Hahaha.
Oh my god!
Oh they're so fast.
I didn't realize how fast they are.
Oh my god!
It's time to run.
Holy shit!
Why are they so fucking fast?
There's nowhere to go.
They can't get up here.
Haha.
Talking nerds.
You guys can't get up here.
I have the high ground now!
That's fucking right!
Alright they're level 53.
I'm not gonna fuck with these guys.
I'm not gonna.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Um.
Oh there they are!
There's a pink chili chilitz!
There's a pink chilitz!
I assume they're like the fire versions of them.
What the fuck!
Hahaha.
They fucking They ran.
I didn't get up here so fast!
Holy shit!
Oh my god I was just chilling up here.
Okay anyway.
Now they're pink.
Now they come in pink now.
Uh.
There's a lot.
There's a lot of new things.
Oh there's a lot of blossoms.
Right there.
Wait that's new?
Are these guys friendly?
I'm gonna assume that nobody's friendly here.
Wait that guy's new?
What's that?
Who's that guy?
Hey!
Oh!
It's the... it's the um.
Fuck.
You know the fox girl?
The other... the other... the fox girl that looks like that Pokemon fox one?
Now it's... now she's red instead of yellow!
Hello.
Are you friendly?
Oh wait no it's a man!
Wait that's a beard.
Oh wait nevermind.
Sorry.
Wait no you are female!
No you're female!
You have a beard!
Oh.
Sorry I saw a beard and just assumed.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry ma'am.
It's a goat!
Yeah.
Wait this is a nice place to live.
I wanna live near the sakura blossoms.
I feel like this should be my new... it's ladybeard.
Yeah.
This could be my new home.
Look all these guys are like super friendly too.
A dancing shrine!
They all seem really nice.
Uh.
I don't feel like they're gonna murder me like the other the other pals that I bumped into.
Look I know I haven't established a home yet guys.
I know but this isn't important.
We've all seen people establish homes like 200 million times.
But this is a new area.
And we're exploring new paths guys.
New friends.
Oh there's so many of the pink guys.
They seem like super common too.
Um.
Yeah we wanna check out the sakura stuff.
Please leave me alone.
I'm trying to take loot.
Wait is that that's... is that new?
I don't think that's new.
I don't think the yellow birds are new.
Cause I'm a yellow bird.
I wonder if I can finally head to the tree.
Is that big tree part of the map now?
I wonder.
I actually don't know if uh.
The.
Oh it's not.
Nope.
Yeah no.
That's another DLC I guess.
That's a.
I think.
I'm pretty sure that's a.
Oh there you go purple ciphers!
More purple ciphers!
Okay that guy is.
Freaking out.
Is that it?
Is there more to this world?
Is there more?
I actually.
I know like there's nothing more after the edge of here.
Uh we're not gonna jump guys.
We are.
We're.
Guys.
I have not found another checkpoint yet.
The closest checkpoint to us is 200 miles away.
And all I have are my legs.
Yes.
They are thick legs.
But it doesn't mean I run faster.
Chat.
I run as fast as a person who has upgraded stamina once.
And even then it's not as fast.
Do a flip.
Alright.
No.
Wait sorry.
I heard the dungeons.
There's some new dungeons as well.
But I feel like dungeons don't really change much in general.
I think my only issue with um.
Well I mean to be fair this is also like with Pokemon.
And my only issue with like these types of games is that um it gets repetitive uh really after a while.
It gets repetitive after a while.
After you play for a certain time.
I think when you get to like the.
Unless you have like uh I think even then if you have like a server filled with others.
It can get repetitive for a bit.
But this is also an issue with um.
Pokemon as well.
That's why I stopped playing Pokemon.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Okay.
I stopped playing Pokemon after uh Paris.
Uh because Oh no.
Uh because.
Oh no.
I fucked up.
Oh no I'm forever.
Oh no I fucked up guys.
Oh no I'm stuck in sparkle mode.
Oh no.
Okay there we go.
Yeah.
The X and Y.
Oh yeah.
Hey look.
Depressed little cat.
You're depressed here too?
Why are you depressed?
Oh because we're at the cemetery.
Okay sorry.
Uh now I know why you're depressed.
I was like why are you depressed here?
There's Sakura blossom.
Wait what did I get?
I got leather.
How can you be depressed?
Oh I'm sorry.
People died here.
That's why.
Are you guys nice people?
Hi.
Yeah?
Hahahaha Hahahaha Alright bye.
Alright.
Pokemon peak with I think.
My favorite Pokemon game was Crystal.
Uh Pokemon Crystal was my favorite Pokemon game.
Um I like.
And also the one where um.
The one where you can have Pokemon follow you around and everything.
Uh I think that one was my favorite as well.
When the Pokemon follows you around and stuff.
I don't remember which one it was.
But I think Pokemon I think Crystal peaked for me.
Alright.
Explore.
Oh my god.
Wait this map is a lot bigger than expected.
That's a lot bigger.
Any other issue I have?
Like um Oh wait hey is that.
That's uh Dark Growlithe.
Dark Growlithe is that you?
Are you good?
Yakumo.
It is.
It's Dark Growlithe.
Oh.
No.
We thought it got a checkpoint.
Oh wait I did.
Okay.
I did.
He respawned here.
And then.
I thought he was a good boy.
I was eyes of a boy.
How was I supposed to know that?
I thought he was a good boy.
That sounds like.
Oh.
Good boy.
Dark Growlithe.
When did they stop being good boys?
Chat.
Oh my god.
I should have expected it when he was.
When he was dark.
I should have expected it.
I knew the darkness overtook.
him.
Stop what I say.
So let us see your new smile.
Thank you Nexy.
Thank you Super Chat.
Thank you.
I'm glad you've been enjoying my new skin suit.
Hmm.
I need to hydrate.
Okay.
Where's my body?
I just.
You know.
I'm like those children that see any type of dog.
And was like.
Oh my god.
I need to pet him.
I need to pet him or her.
Which is not really good.
Because like.
Children should not.
Like.
Be that open towards petting strange.
Petting random stranger dogs.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
I can't help it.
Oh my god.
Um.
I don't know if I've ever told this story before.
But like.
Uh.
What's it?
No.
Okay.
It was like one of my older older dogs.
Um.
And uh.
And like.
Um.
It was so scary.
Because like.
We were.
I was walking.
I was walking him.
And then.
Oh wait.
Stop.
Get away from my food.
Get away from my backpack.
Oh wait.
No.
He's not.
Okay.
Never mind.
He's not close to my backpack.
He's not.
Ha ha ha.
Sorry.
I wasn't trying.
I wasn't judging you.
I just assumed that.
You know.
It's not because you're pink.
I'm sorry.
Uh.
Ha ha ha.
Okay.
Um.
And then like.
Another dog.
Like ran up to my other dog.
Oh there he is.
There's dark ground leaf.
Another dog like ran up to my dog.
And like.
It was scary.
Because it looked like he was gonna like.
Um.
He was gonna like bite him.
It wasn't even a big dog.
It was like the same size.
It was like beagle-esque type deal.
And then.
Instead of like.
Um.
Instead of.
I don't.
I don't know.
Because I got scolded.
Because I should not have like.
Cause like.
If that dog bit me.
And like.
What if he had rabies?
Ha ha ha.
Okay.
To be fair.
If he had rabies.
Then he would not be a pet dog.
But like.
I.
I like.
Instead of like pulling my dog away.
I like push the other dog away.
Uh.
Ha ha ha.
You know.
I could have like.
Try to pick up my dog.
Or like.
You know.
Uh.
Try to yank.
Like.
Put myself in between.
Try to put myself in between.
But instead.
I just pushed him away.
Ha ha ha.
Just like.
No.
Ha ha ha.
And then I.
And then I got.
And then he like nipped my hand.
It wasn't even like a pin fall.
Ha ha ha.
You know.
Apparently.
You're supposed to like.
Uh.
You're supposed to.
Um.
You're supposed to get yourself in between.
But instead.
I just like pushed him.
Ha ha ha.
And then he like.
He like.
Like.
Not like.
Bite my hand.
But he was just like.
Rrrr.
Like my hand.
So there was like a mark on it.
But it wasn't like.
It wasn't like a cut.
Or anything.
Uh.
Ha ha.
And then.
And then I got scolded by.
Uh.
By the owner.
And my parents.
Because they were like.
What are you.
Are you fucking stupid?
Ha ha ha.
I was like.
I.
I don't know.
Like.
It was like the first thought in my head.
I didn't want him to fucking bite my dog.
Like.
At least I didn't kick him.
Why.
I was scared.
I was scared he was gonna bite my dog.
So I like.
Pushed him away.
Like.
I like bent down.
And just pushed him away.
Ha ha ha.
Um.
Uh.
Vernon.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey Dokia.
Love your new look.
I want to recreate your revolver.
Is there.
Any.
Uh.
Detail reference for it.
Or where may I find it.
Thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Um.
If you look at my Twitter.
I actually posted the.
Full reference sheet.
Um.
Of what my new skin suit looks like.
Alright guys.
After I claim this.
Um.
This checkpoint.
We're gonna actually make a home now.
We're gonna for real have like a place to live.
Whoa.
Wait.
That's pretty.
Okay.
We're gonna have a place to live for real now.
We're not gonna be homeless.
Like.
I know I look homeless right now.
But this.
I swear to god.
I know.
We have not had a home in a while.
But don't worry.
Now.
That we figured this game out.
Figured a new place now.
Now.
We're gonna have a home.
We're gonna build our home here for now.
Because.
Um.
I don't know about you guys.
But.
Um.
You know.
Everybody else over there.
Is like super OP.
And we need like some form of like.
We need somewhere to live.
We.
We actually need some place to live.
Um.
Also like.
I didn't mention it before.
But like.
One of the reasons why.
Like I like to keep my new skin suit.
It is simpler.
I wanna keep it simple.
Is that.
Um.
I'm here for the cosplayers out there.
Other than my hair.
Like.
And like I guess gun.
.
Other than my hair.
And um.
Gun.
Um.
It is easier.
.
It's easy and memorable.
That was like my goal.
Um.
Yeah.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh.
Let's see.
I'm trying to figure out where.
I guess we can live here.
I mean there's rocks here.
There's trees.
There's rocks.
I think the only issue is that.
The mine.
The.
Uh.
Ores is like.
So far away.
That's like.
The only issue I have.
Unless there's like a better place.
Uh.
MC.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello.
This is my first chat to you.
Thank you for making me laugh every day.
Um.
I'm planning to make a doki plushie.
Yee.
Meow.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Alright.
We only have an issue.
And like.
I don't know where the.
The ores are so far away.
That's the only issue.
Cause this is normal rock.
This is just regular rock.
And we're gonna need ores soon.
So.
Uh.
Yeah.
Oh there is ore mines.
You're right.
Wait.
I don't have to worry about that.
Is there ore mines?
Oh.
Shit.
Okay.
Oh.
Shit!
Okay.
I was not paying attention.
No.
Okay.
I was not paying attention.
I was fucking around.
Alright.
This is a little Iffy.
Okay.
We're gonna.
Um.
Okay.
We're.
We're fine.
Or we can live here!
There's a rock.
There's one ore mine.
And... oh there's a boar.
There's a boar.
Okay.
Everything wants to kill me.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything might want to kill me.
But everything is okay.
Everything...
Yes.
Everything might want to... okay how about... oh I figured it out.
Alright.
We're gonna be here.
So we have...
Oh here is nice.
Cause we have the trees and we have that one rock.
That one rock is gonna last us forever.
Oh shit.
Okay.
That was a mistake.
I mean I have so many.
Yay!
I have a chick.
Okay.
That... I... that was...
I mean that works.
Okay.
New friend.
We have...
Dragoon.
New friend.
I did not mean to catch you.
But I guess you're here now.
Anyway.
I need to... I need to build a...
...Promitive... New friend!
New... New friend.
Wait.
What do you do again?
I forgot what does the chicken do.
You are useless.
Okay.
I mean...
You're so special.
Dragoon.
You're... You're so...
Don't ever let them call you useless.
Cause you're special to me.
Alright.
I need to craft... I need to build a...
What the fuck?
Alright.
This is your first job.
You're fine.
Okay.
Let me...
And now I have to build a...
I need to build a POW box.
Oh I don't have enough wood.
Okay.
You'll be fine.
You do your thing.
Look.
I'm looking at your HP to make sure you're okay.
Okay.
I should have...
I should have enough.
You'll be fine.
See.
Look at you.
You're doing it.
I don't even have to look.
I know you're doing it.
Look.
Oh my god.
What?
You killed him?
Oh my... I knew... I knew it Dragoon.
I knew you were never useless.
I knew you were just as good as all of the...
Don't let those others Dragoon.
Don't let all those other VTuber mascots pick on you Dragoon.
I knew you were never useless.
You...
Wait.
POW dressing facility?
I can dress you up?
Don't let them.
You might...
Your only job is just to lay eggs.
We know... You know your purpose.
Guys.
You know your purpose Dragoons.
Like you might be only able to lay eggs.
And you're not able to do... mine anything or contribute to the base.
But...
You can lay eggs.
And you beat up a boar.
And that's all that matters to me.
Um...
You guys got this.
Wait.
We don't have like the fragments.
So that's a little bit of an issue.
I need to find...
Uh...
I need to find like a thing to mine the fragments.
Wait.
Are you female?
Are you?
No.
Wait.
You lay eggs?
But you're...
You're special.
You're my special Dragoon.
Alright.
Um...
What do I need?
Crab cloth to...
Oh.
I need cloth.
You're right.
Uh...
Cloth time.
Alright.
Yay!
Wait.
There's another Dragoon over there?
Yeah.
But he's not as good as that Dragoon.
Go over there and beat him up.
No.
You're not supposed to be friends with him.
Hit him!
Oh my god.
Dragoon!
It's survival of the fittest!
Now hit him.
That's right.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Let's see.
What do the lambs do?
Lambs work, right?
I don't remember.
Might as well.
Alright.
I gotta...
Get over here.
I need you in my army.
There you go.
We're friends.
No.
There's no friends in PAL world.
Haha.
Only PAL.
Only workers.
Hahaha.
No friends.
Only workers in PAL world.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh.
Sorry.
The only issue right now is the fact that...
Hahaha.
It's binded to the numbers.
Okay.
Now you can work.
Alright.
What do you do again?
You are...
You're a worker!
Okay.
Go work.
Go be a good pal and work for me.
Alright.
Hahaha.
Bring...
Okay.
I'll bring it up.
Uh...
I'm not your pal, buddy.
Berrita, thank you for the acca soup.
Thank you.
Alright.
Bring it up to 75.
Okay.
Here you go.
Alright.
Yes.
Let's see.
What do we need?
PALs will bed.
We'll get stressed.
Well, I guess it's time...
Hahaha.
Guys, this is not a bad company.
Okay?
I need you guys to know that this...
This...
Hahaha.
Look.
You guys willingly worked here.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Let's see.
I need a crab cloth and equipment and prepare for a chill night.
Okay.
How much is a cloth?
I need two.
Alright.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
Hahaha.
Finish that.
I'm a supervisor.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Let's see.
What do I need?
I need to...
We need to up these two the most, I feel like.
And then we'll put a little bit...
Um...
Craft the cloth.
Oh, yeah.
We need the...
We need to be able to craft the cloth.
Craft the cloth.
Get over here!
That's right.
Hahaha.
That's fucking right.
I supervise.
You work.
Hahaha.
And then you pay me.
That's fucking right.
Hahaha.
Work, Lambel.
Work.
Hahaha.
Don't make me grab my dragoon over here for the muscle.
Alright.
Oh, yeah.
What do we call you?
Look.
He's happy working.
You work till you die.
Hahaha.
Yay!
I have clothes now.
Hahaha.
Do we get day up?
Haha.
You think you have rights?
Hahaha.
Uh...
Let's see.
We need wood, stone, and fiber.
How do we make fiber again?
I don't remember.
Oh, wait.
It's like we gotta chop the trees into...
Uh...
Wait.
What am I doing?
I can, like, make an axe.
God, it's been so long.
Okay.
I need rocks.
Alright.
The sheep will be...
Oh, you're right.
Let me rename you, sheep.
It's naming time.
It's your naming...
It's naming time, little guy.
You get to be named.
Chunky.
Goon.
Oh, my God.
You get to be named.
Chunky.
Congratulations!
Isn't that great?
You get to be named!
Alright.
Let's see, I need a...
I need to grab some more rocks.
Alright, come over here.
Come over here, dragons.
We need rocks now.
Alright, nice.
Grab some berries.
And we gotta beat up some fucking rocks, cause we are...
Can I beat up rocks?
I'm pretty sure, right?
We don't need the axe.
Slow and steady.
Oh yeah, okay.
It's been a while.
It's been a while since I played Palworld.
Welcome Chang'un to the mines.
Nice.
You're a lucky dragon.
You're a very lucky dragon.
Because you were here first.
So you get treated the best.
You get special treatment.
But don't tell the others.
They'll just know from the way I treat you versus the others.
The first goon.
You're like my enforcer.
You're like my enforcer dragon.
If the other goons are out of line, you're here to enforce them.
Any means necessary.
Alright, let's see.
If we catch enough lamb bells, or if we catch enough chonky goons, it's okay if one gets sick.
We'll just replace it with the other.
I'm not a bad person, right?
Alright, let's see.
We have the rocks now.
So we need to be able to get this.
Alright, where are you?
Where are you lamb bell?
That's fucking great.
That.
There we go.
Look!
Chonky goon is happy!
You can't say!
You can't say that!
Because chonky goon is happy working.
How did you get this?
He's so happy!
Look at him!
Every time we make something, he smiles.
What does that say?
Chat?
He's happy whenever he makes stuff for me.
Look at there.
Look at my enforcer.
Watching me.
Making sure everything is okay.
Alright, let's grab this.
Is there anything else?
We need to find paladin fragments.
That's one of the only things we're missing.
It's just...
We need to find a place for the fragments and stuff.
Uhhhh...
Let's see.
We don't really need...
Porches, I feel like.
We don't need that.
We definitely need the stone pit and the logging pit.
Oh, it's the bat.
Yeah, I want the bat.
We need the crusher.
We need hot springs.
I guess.
We need the forge.
There's a bear trap?
Oh, okay.
We need nests.
I think that's fine.
Okay.
Let's see.
Can we make those now?
We need fragments, stone, and wood.
Okay, actually can I upgrade?
Oh yeah.
The thing is...
You don't need a bed.
Because Chunky Goon, all I'm saying...
Do you know why I know you don't need a bed?
Well, the thing is...
Chunky Goon...
I made it so the day will never come.
So the day will never end.
The day's never gonna end.
So you never have to sleep.
So you can get stressed...
If the night never shows up.
You don't need to get stressed if it's never night.
Night time.
No night, no break.
It's only...
We still have plenty of day.
I don't remember how to make fiber though.
I think that's the only issue I have.
Let's see.
Oh yeah, I need to put...
Inventory time!
My eyes light up when I get to look at my inventory.
Woooo!
Inventory!
Wait, I thought I picked up my axe.
Oh, I didn't.
Okay, nice.
Can I get transported on night shift?
Thank you for the super chat, Kevin.
Thank you, thank you.
The funny thing is that...
There's no way I can get to the night shift.
There's no night shift.
It's always day.
Silly goon.
Thinking that day actually exists.
Silly, silly.
Alright, let's grab some wood.
Cause I think we need wood.
We need wood and like...
What else do we need?
I don't remember actually.
I'm gonna grab some fucking ores too.
Real fast.
Other opportu- The only way to get promoted...
Is to kill the first dragoon.
If you kill the first dragoon...
You get...
You get to be...
You get promoted.
There's only one promotion in this...
In this world.
Alright, I'll just...
I guess I'll make one bed.
I'll...
I'll say...
Work for your bed.
That's fucking right.
If you want a bed, you gotta work on it yourself.
Um...
One must imagine Chonky goon happy.
Thank you for the super chat, Alan.
Thank you, thank you.
That's right.
You won a bed.
Remember what happened in Pikmin if you try to unionize.
I...
You guys wanna know what happens if you unionize?
Don't worry, I'll show you what happens soon.
I...
Don't worry.
You'll see.
You'll see what happens.
Nooooo!
Alright, let's grab some rocks real fast.
We still need to find, like, the...
Um...
The fragments.
We still don't have the fragments yet.
Uh...
Daisy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Kill the goon ahead of you and every goon and you go on one rank.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Honestly, thank you for the super chat.
It's a wonder people voluntarily work with you when you joke like this.
It is a joke, right?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
Alright, let's see.
We gotta find the fragments.
It's harder here because this is normally not where I would put my first base.
But like, it's the closest to the new world.
Like, I need to get to the new world.
The new world is right beside me.
I need to head there.
Where the fuck is the fragments?
I don't know where the fragments are.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Who are you?
Where is Doki?
It's me.
I've always been Doki.
Where the fuck?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is that?
Has that always been there?
Why is there like four fucking eggs?
What kind of spawn is that?
What the...
Has it always been like this?
There's so many... what?
There's so many fucking eggs.
There's a family over there.
The council meeting.
Is that... oh, I didn't know.
I didn't realize wolves came from...
I didn't realize wolves came from fucking eggs.
Oh my god.
It came from eggs?
Well, I guess like all pals come from eggs in the end.
Alright.
Where are the paladin fragments?
I swear to god.
I literally... all I need are the fragments.
But I have not found like... those like mineable fragment shit in this area.
Like you would assume this is like a spawn area.
So...
What the fuck?
They're over here?
They live here too?
Oh my god.
I want a frog.
What do you do?
That's fucking right.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh my god.
They're baby frogs.
They exist.
Holy shit.
The baby frogs exist.
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh, 93?
Alright.
Let's see here.
Oh my god.
They're real.
They have a baby version of them?
They're not level 43.
Oh my god.
It's over.
It's over for them.
God.
I don't... Oh there's a fragment.
Nice.
We need the fragment too.
We really need to find more places for the fragment.
It's still day.
It's never gonna be night time.
You're using megaballs?
Exactly.
And?
Yeah.
You're seeing it as if it's a bad thing.
Guys.
I don't remember what my 2 does.
What does my 2 does anyway?
I'll never... I'll never know.
Alright.
Oh there's more.
We need more fragments.
There you go.
Do the normal rocks give fragments?
I thought it was...
Oh wait.
The cats are good workers.
Get over here.
Okay.
Alright Dragoon.
Look.
I know you're bloodthirsty right now.
I know.
I know you're...
I know you're bloodthirsty right now.
Do I get fragments from... I thought it was like...
I thought it was like...
You need like a special rock for it.
It's been so long.
I didn't realize these also give fragments.
They give normal fragments?
Yeah.
I thought they would give like...
I thought they give like normal...
Oh my god.
You can fight them.
I don't care.
Oh stones dropped them?
Oh shit.
Okay.
What am I doing?
I should have just been doing this this entire time.
Alright.
Wait.
Do the frogs do anything?
What is your job?
What do you have?
You...
You gather.
You water.
You...
And... Oh.
Handiwork transport.
Okay.
And...
Oh.
Handiwork transport.
Okay.
Nice.
Give me the fragment.
Oh I can find them near water?
Guys you can tell it's been a while.
You can tell it's been a while since I played this.
Alright.
Get away.
Get away frogs.
Alright.
Let's go back home.
And...
We go back home and see if we can find the fragments over on the edge of the...
near the water.
We need to find...
Wait.
There's a chest here.
There's a purple...
Do I have purple key?
I do.
I got gold coin.
Alright.
Let's see if there's anything here.
Oh wait.
I can upgrade.
Stamina.
There you go.
Can I do it?
No.
Alright.
Nice.
It's night time.
It's night time dragon.
Dragon!
It's nighttime.
You think you can sleep?
You may be my number one enforcer, but that means you never sleep.
It's only work time.
You're right, there's only one.
Your shift is 24 hours.
Seven days a week.
TASKARU, I love to work!
Yay!
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Home is this way.
Uh, what's this?
Dark skill fruit poison blast?
I've never seen this before.
That's the first time I've seen that.
Uh, oh no, we're Amazon workers!
Alright.
Guys, we're almost home!
We're almost home!
Guys!
How's my good worker?
Is my good worker having a good time?
Alright, let's see.
I haven't seen my family in nine weeks.
You don't have a family anymore.
The only family you have is us.
Alright.
Oh nice, you leveled up, my little guy.
Let's see.
Where's the, where's the, where's the Chonky Goon?
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Wait, where did he go?
Um, alright, we gotta build.
Wait, actually, no.
What am I doing?
We have to build the stone pit.
We have to build the stone pit first.
We'll build the stone pit here.
Alright.
Where is he?
Where are you?
That's right.
You thought you could hide, but I know you love to work.
I know you love to work.
Two minutes?
Yeah.
Alright, let's...
You do that, and then I'm gonna...
I need wood.
Alright, give me a sec.
It's okay.
Although we can't see anything, it's okay.
I know.
You thought... I knew you love work, so it's okay.
The moment... You thought you could hide, but the moment I put that shit down, you come back to work like a good dragon.
You know you can't avoid it.
Okay, I'll do this myself, because it's three seconds.
I guess I'll try a little.
Uh...
No, we have enough...
Wait.
Oh.
Yep.
Can't stop.
You think you can stop?
You still have a long way to go.
Guys.
You think...
Oh!
You think you're go...
You think you can just sleep?
No, no, no.
Wait.
Yes, you can.
Never mind.
I guess you can.
Okay.
That... That ruins things a little bit.
What do you mean you can just leave?
This is not what I planned!
I also put...
The bed here too.
Wait.
I can't build here?
Okay.
Just put it here.
Alright.
Sleep while you sleep.
I still can't.
Oh, the night is going...
The night is going by so fast.
In like 10 seconds.
It's okay.
You're awake for like...
Um...
For like 18 hours and you sleep 1 hour.
Wait.
Sorry.
23 hours.
You're awake for 23 hours and you get 1 hour of sleep.
Every day.
Is that great, guys?
Okay.
I should eat.
And I guess you get 2 berries too.
Because I feel a little generous.
Alright.
It's time to wake up.
It's work time.
It builds morale.
Exactly.
You understand.
Let's see.
Do I still have...
I still don't have enough for a shield.
I'm gonna find like a place to grab fragments.
It's so difficult.
Let's see.
That's literally all I need.
Just like a place for fragments.
Woo!
Okay.
I hope there's stuff here.
Right?
There might be stuff here.
Okay.
That's...
Well, we need you for berries anyway.
So...
Go.
Go, dragoons.
I believe in you.
Come on.
You're literally level 12.
You're that fucking beast.
You're like a bush.
We beat you up.
That's fucking right.
Kill the plants.
Endgame.
I love the environment.
God damn.
All right.
That's fine.
I don't really care.
I know it's a mega sphere, but I can literally swim to the level...
Wait.
What?
Oh, shit.
I thought you were captured.
All right.
Beat the berries out of her.
Nice.
Okay.
Yes, I'm level 13 now.
Yay!
Let's see if I'm with the fragments.
Yes, I know I'm using the Megasphere, but I can literally go to the Forbidden Lands and pick up 20 of them.
Like, easy.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Today is my birthday!
Thank you for giving us a good time every time!
Your voice makes me smile!
I love you, Dokie!
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear you!
Yeah!
Oh wait, there's more Paladin fragments.
That's good.
We actually need that.
Oh!
The Paladin fragments are so difficult to find!
This is a terrible... Why did you guys make me spawn?
No, I'm joking.
I'm joking, it's not your fault.
Sorry, it was just instinct.
Blaming others is just instinct right now.
Because it's never the streamer's fault.
It's never the streamer's fault, guys.
Okay, but we're a family now.
Chat, we're a family.
And family takes responsibility together.
Oh...
Dope.
Guys... we're a family, right?
Guys...
Remember, we're a family.
We're a family.
Alright, we gotta get the pickaxe.
We gotta get that bench.
We gotta... we don't need medicine.
If you're sick, we'll just replace you.
Alright.
Dragos get night pay for this.
When the night is like 30 seconds, I don't think anybody is getting paid for 30 seconds of work.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Nyx!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Love your new skin so keep being... keep on being you.
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
Uh...
What's he doing in the water?
Is he stupid?
What the fuck is he doing trying to swim?
Alright.
Everyone, run for the hills.
All I'm saying is...
Don't make me angry.
Guys, I might... I might force... I'm gonna... I'm gonna loot... swap bases.
This base fucking sucks.
I'm gonna go to my usual base.
There's barely any fragments here.
This is like the worst area to start.
I know... Whenever I get higher level, I move back.
Like, fuck this area.
Drop one!
No!
What do you mean?
I'm sorry!
I didn't notice!
I'm just stupid!
Alright, guys.
We're moving!
Guys!
It's time to move!
Okay, how do I...
How do I... How do I fucking destroy this?
I don't remember.
Guys, how do you destroy stuff again?
Uh...
Oh, it's a C?
It's...
Okay, it's B.
Okay, how do I destroy this?
How do I destroy stuff again?
I'm trying to remember how...
Oh, do I just hit it?
B and C...
Oh!
Okay.
Oh, I had to assemble.
Yes.
Uh...
No beds for you guys.
No.
Oh!
Oh, this is bad.
Uh...
This is very bad.
Nope.
Okay.
I'm gonna... You're gonna eat your own child first.
And then we're gonna fucking throw this away really fast.
And then...
We're going to...
You're gonna stay in my pocket.
And...
We're gonna destroy you too!
Goodbye.
We don't live here anymore.
We'll come back for you.
Now we don't need any of these.
Alright.
Come on, guys.
We're going... We're going back to where...
Where the default spawn is.
We'll come back to the new world soon.
I swear to God.
All I wanna do is...
You know what?
I'll just have Dragoon be like super fucking strong.
And then we're gonna swim there.
We're returning home!
Back to where we all started!
Alright.
It's okay.
It's okay, Dragoon!
We're almost there!
Alright.
I'm fucking... I'm going back here.
Oh my God, no!
Wait.
What the...
Oh no, I forgot!
I forgot!
Okay.
I have a plan.
I have a plan, guys.
I have a plan!
Okay.
Guys.
We're gonna get a little...
We're gonna get a little quirky here.
Okay.
I didn't think this through.
Okay, we're gonna get a little quirkier, guys.
Alright, let's put these guys away first.
And then, and then we'll put away the important stuff.
And then, plan B!
We have figured this out!
Exactly!
Back to where it all started!
Alright!
Nice!
Alright, guys.
It's like nothing...
Look, see?
It's that easy.
There we go.
Okay.
Alright, and I get free stuff!
Look, see?
I got free stuff, guys!
Alright, and then back here!
EW!
Easy!
And there it is!
I told you, guys!
Not that difficult.
I'll take all of that away and I'll just leave this chest here because I'm lazy right now.
Um...
Nothing bad happened!
Yeah, see?
I'm just taking advantage of the mechanics, chat.
I'm just taking advantage of them.
And then, we live here.
This is like...
See?
This is what I mean!
This is literally all the good shit!
Look at all these fragments!
I was like, where the fuck are the fragments?
This is like the best place to ever...
Why would you spawn anywhere else?
Well, not here.
But like, um...
Down here.
I usually place my base right there.
Because it literally has everything I need.
It has the ores, the fragments, the...
The sheep I'm gonna beat up and let my anger out.
Um...
And see, everything is there.
Everything we ever need!
Is right here!
It's like THE spot to build.
Um... I'll build it here.
Alright.
Here we go.
No matter, even if there's a new update.
This is always like THE place to be.
Alright, frog, sheep.
Alright guys.
And then...
Oh my god!
I can dress you guys up now!
Wait.
What is this?
Alright, work.
WORK!
Yes, work!
Yes!
Good!
My good workers!
That's right!
Only one hour has passed.
Since...
Only one day hour has passed.
Change the skin?
Oh!
That's what it does?
Oh my god!
Where's the cat?
Get over here.
I need you to have glasses.
Alright.
Oh my god!
Yeah!
You're cool now!
You're so cool!
Alright.
You're not cool enough.
Oh my god!
What does he do?
He mines!
Look at him!
He's cool now!
He's so cool!
Alright.
What do I need to upgrade?
I need a primitive workbench and a shoddy bed.
Okay.
That works.
So now I can have Chonky Goon back in there.
Wait.
Who should he be?
The cooler goon?
Oh you're right.
Okay.
Uh...
The cooler goon.
Can't see my tears behind those shades.
Thank you for the super chat, Cass.
Thank you.
Ani!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Fun trick.
You can detonate your base console remotely and retrieve the resource to rebuild it from anywhere.
Good for moving lots of stuff easier.
My gosh!
Why didn't I know this before?
Alright.
Let's see.
Uh...
Skins obtained inside and outside of the game can be applied here.
So I guess you might be able to unlock stuff?
To have...
To like...
I guess like to...
Uh...
To like dress up your paths?
That's right.
That's good.
You wear the glasses so they don't know how much you're not getting paid.
That's right.
If they can't see the tears, Are you actually crying?
Are you actually crying?
If you think about it.
Okay, we need the workbench.
All I'm seeing is...
Pal- Pal- Pal-San decreased while doing more, causing them to slack off.
Who's slacking off?
Who is it?
Who's slacking off right now?
Who is at home?
Uhhh.
Let's see...
Alright...
And then...
How do I make a roof?
There we go.
Uhhh...
There.
That's all we need.
Now build my bed!
Build my bed!
What's your name?
You need a new name.
When you work for Doki Production Incorporated, you get a new name.
Be gone with your old name!
Frog-Goon.
You get a new name when you work for Doki Bird.
Eliminate your past self!
This is new you.
You're right.
It should be one word.
You're right, guys.
Frog-Goon.
There we go.
Nice!
He built my bed.
Yeah, and if anyone's slacking off, you gotta pay me.
Oh, okay.
I don't even need a door.
That's great.
I just...
Let's see.
Can I upgrade my base so I can put Chonky-Goon back in here?
Chonky-Goon is back to work time.
It's work time again, Chonky-Goon.
Hey, um...
What do I need to upgrade this?
I think we're making good progress.
Feed box?
You guys need food?
Wait.
Are you trying to tell me you need food?
You need to be fed?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, I need wood, too.
The pals of a corner.
That's hilarious.
Please don't make me laugh so much.
Alright, let's see.
I need to be able to... wait.
Can I create it?
Where's my workbench?
Where is my workbench?
Oh, I see.
Good thing I have my pickaxe.
Alright, let's see.
Let's grab these ores real fast.
Alright.
I gotta create some stuff.
I need to create some certain things real quick, guys.
Stone and flame organs.
Okay, I clearly don't have enough stone and I need to kill some foxes, too.
Alright, guys.
Give me a sec.
Doki needs to head off for some bus...
Doki needs to head off on a business trip real fast, guys.
Give me a bit.
Doki, please.
Guys, give me a sec.
Doki needs to go on a business trip.
With a little bit of murder.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We already get negative pay, but you slack off, you'll get more negatives faster.
Especially...
What is it?
Especially hugs?
Unless you're into that sort of thing, I guess.
Yeah, I know.
Hugs, right?
There's no censorship here.
Thank you for the super chat, Johnny.
Thank you, thank you.
Where are the flame guys?
Where are they?
Where are the...
Where are the fire tails?
I know you exist.
I've seen you guys around.
No need to hide.
I've seen you roaming around.
I wanna give a hug.
Where are you lot?
I've seen you guys travel around here.
Alright, let's see.
We might have to go back to the original home to see if we can find the flame boys.
Don't worry.
Flame boy.
Where are you?
Where are you flame boy?
Now I just think you the super chat.
Thank you.
Your new skin suit really suits you, Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I know.
It shows how kind I am.
It really does.
Uhh...
Where are the flame boys?
I've seen your tails flying around before.
I know you're alive...
for now.
Heeeeyyyy...
Flame boys...
Where are you?
Why do I have an axe to say?
I just wanted to ask you something.
You know?
It's just a little joke.
You know what?
I want this guy.
You work for me now.
I'm gonna duck your fam- I'm gonna duck you like a kid.
Alright.
You will never see your family again.
You're level 2 so you're almost a child.
Yay!
You're gonna work on my company!
You're gonna work in my company now!
Yay!
Just wanna ask you a little question.
I adopted him.
He had no family, guys.
That poor little monkey...
had no family.
Oh my god.
It was so sad.
He had no family and I adopted him.
Oh my god.
Now he's gonna be okay now.
Chat.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh there you are.
There you are!
Oh you're gonna run.
You know what's gonna happen to you.
You're gonna run.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ooh.
You think you can run away?
That's really cute.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh he does think he can run away.
Oh I'm so cute.
Oh get over here.
I don't even need to catch you.
I just need your fucking organ.
It's organ transplant time.
I'm here to take your kidneys.
Yay!
Alright nice.
We did it.
Run for your life.
Nice!
I got...
Oh nice.
Okay I need one more.
Alright.
No!
Ha ha ha ha.
Alright let's see.
Oh there's more of that frog guys.
Alright I don't care about these guys though.
They do not...
We're gonna make sure they're extinct.
They get endangered.
Ha ha ha ha.
Not organ trafficking.
What are you guys talking about?
What the fuck is wrong with them?
Are they sleeping?
What's going on?
Are they okay?
Did I kill them?
When did I kill these guys?
Who killed them?
Wait I didn't kill them.
Then who did?
Ha ha ha ha.
I didn't kill them at all.
Oh it's the syndicate.
How dare they?
They're taking my job!
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh there's more.
There they are.
Alright Dragoon you can take care of the syndicate.
I need to harvest some organs real fast.
Alright.
Alright get over here.
You know what?
I need one of you guys.
I don't need two though.
Ha ha ha ha.
I just need one.
That's cute.
You're fucking right.
That's Doki's job.
That's fucking right.
Get over here.
There you go.
I just need one of you.
Alright nice.
Alright.
I'm just gonna watch this.
You guys won't die Dragoon.
You're literally level 15.
How are you gonna die?
There we go.
Good job.
Now I'm gonna fucking loot them.
Yay!
Look they have a bounty.
I'm here to collect it.
Dead.
It says dead or alive and I chose dead.
Alright.
Time to head home Dragoons.
Time to head home.
I needed one of the fire guys so I can make the ores.
Uh, Duck thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki is a really kind boss.
I once asked for a raise and she doubled my pay.
T-Bite was negative before she doubled it.
Ha ha ha ha.
Yeah that's unfortunate man.
Uh, how do I head home?
What is this way?
Alright.
Oh I can level up though.
Level up time.
Uh?
Work speed, weight, and stamina.
I don't really need health.
Not gonna lie.
Alright.
I'm so generous.
Look at my testimonies.
You don't believe me?
Read all the testimonies right now.
They all call me kind.
If I wasn't so kind.
If I wasn't such a good boss.
Where would I get all these testimonies chat?
DarkBlade, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
I work at Doki Dragoon Construction Agency and I love it.
Doki is a great leader and would never hurt us.
She turned my life around.
I speak 100% truth and totally am not...
See?
And you should join today.
Yeah!
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
DarkBlade, remember when you were an orphan and I took you in?
You know?
I found you and took you in, DarkBlade.
And I gave you a job and a pay and everything.
I gave you a bed to sleep, DarkBlade.
Remember that?
Where the fuck is the...
Where the fuck is the teleporter?
Alright, let's see.
It's not kidnapping!
He needed a home.
Well, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Capture a rebel and name him Sound Guy.
We need a manager.
Alright, let's see.
It's over here.
There's the teleporter.
They all hid in here.
Then why are they still here?
Huh?
Why did they let me capture them?
This is 10% of what I captured.
They could break out at any time they want.
That's on them.
That's all I'm saying.
They did not have this work here.
They could just... Why don't you just leave?
Alright.
Let's see.
Alright, let's see.
We need to upgrade our...
Oh yeah, we have...
We can afford the... this now.
Alright, nice.
Let's make this...
Wait, who said that?
Kevin Ashwell.
Okay, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, Kevin.
Don't worry, Kevin.
I see you.
I see you, Kevin.
Give me a sec, Kevin.
I need to start producing...
something first.
Don't worry, Kevin.
People will remember you.
I don't need...
I'm patient.
I'm...
We can wait here is long as we want.
Thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Tokio is such a kind boss.
My house burn down and Tokio is right outside to offer me a bed and a job.
Thank you for the superchat, Ai-fulness, thank you, thank Thank you!
See?
Look at all these testimonials!
About how great of a boss I am!
Chat?
Let's see...
Let me grab something real quick.
Well, this is burning.
I need to grab something real quick, guys.
I need...
Yeah!
Look at all of those!
It's okay, guys.
I can wait.
I'm patient here.
Where to sleep and eat?
Good question.
Zia!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
I feel very called out right now.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Mercy!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Doki was kind and took care of me.
Took me in after I lost my family to that axe-wielding organ office.
Oh my god!
Who could it be?
Who would do such a thing?
That's so fucked up!
Who would just harvest organs just willy-nilly like that?
Oh my... I would never.
I'm a con boss.
I took them in when they had nobody to support them.
Roar!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Coming home after a long day at work.
To hear you laughing.
It's all worth it!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you for the 10 gifted chips!
And Sean!
Welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Alright, guys.
Okay.
See?
They're happy.
They're a happy worker.
Alright.
Oh, where's my work desk?
Okay.
Let's see.
Wait.
No.
Okay.
Wait.
Alright.
Alright, Kevin.
Make it.
That's right, Kevin.
Make that cleaner.
Hey, Kevin!
Why don't you tell me more about your ideas to unionize, Kevin?
I would love to hear more about it while you're making that cleaver.
Um...
Why don't you... Why don't you tell me more?
I'd love to hear about it.
Like, what are your ideas?
What are your... What started these ideas in your head?
Um...
Come on, Kevin.
You were so into this idea before!
Kevin.
Why don't you tell me more?
I'm so curious!
I'm really, really curious!
Uh...
I feel like... You know what?
You were right.
Maybe we should unionize, man.
Maybe... Maybe we should!
You were right!
I just... I need to know some of these brilliant ideas you had!
Oh, you're happy?
Oh, you did a good job, Kevin!
You did such a good job!
Oh, my God!
You... You did such a good job, man!
You're happy, right?
You're such a happy worker!
You're such a... You're such a happy worker, man!
I beg of you!
Why, guys?
Why are you scared?
I don't understand!
Why are you guys all so scared for Kevin?
Chat!
He's... He's doing his best!
Alright, Kevin.
Wow.
You had... Let me look at your resume real quick.
Let me look at your report!
Your report!
See... Uh...
Let me... Let me look at your report real quick.
Oh, I almost forgot.
Alright, Kevin.
Get over here.
You know... Let me take you to a business trip, Kevin.
No, no.
Actually... Let's get all the folks here.
Let's get all your friends here, too, guys.
Let's get... Let's get all your friends here.
All your friends are here.
Aren't you happy?
They all wanna see you!
They all... wanna see you!
That's right!
Alright.
Nice.
And I think...
Kevin who?
We never had a Kevin.
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
We never had a Kevin in this company.
Oh...
What I do know...
is that...
You all love working here, right, Dragons?
You all love it here, right?
Nobody knew a Kevin.
There's no records of a Kevin that worked in Doki Bird Production Incorporated.
That's right!
Batty is so much fun!
T .A.L.K.O.s, thanks for the super chat.
Thank you.
Blood for the blood... timeframe...
Yeah!
See?
Cleaver!
This is the pickaxe, guys!
What are you guys talking about?
This is a...
This is just a pickaxe.
We don't have a Cleaver here.
All right!
Anyway.
I feel like...
What do we need?
Ummm...
I feel like we're... high enough level to...
Let's see...
Let me just...
Let me see.
What technology can I have?
I can have a mill, a wheat plantation...
Ooh, a monitoring stage!
I love those!
That's gonna be good for us in the future.
Sphere workshop...
Ooh, a viewing cage!
Yep.
Alright!
Mr. Brokenbond, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Remember his words?
Mr. Brokenbonds?
Alright, give me a sec here.
What a cute little chicken.
Let me adopt you real fast.
Let me adopt you.
Who said that?
Alright.
I'm gonna take you here.
Let's see...
Whoops.
Yeah.
You know what they say over here?
You know- Oh, you wanna get out of the water?
No, no, no.
You don't get out of the water, Mr. Brokenbonds.
You stay in the water.
Oh.
Are you drowning, sir?
What were your final words again?
What'd you say?
Oh, Mr. Brokenbonds.
Oh.
Wait, why are you running away?
Why are you running away?
I don't understand.
Hmm?
Oh, don't worry.
You were a good worker, Mr. Brokenbonds.
A very, very good worker.
That's right.
Look at the waterfall.
Alright.
There's never a Mr. Brokenbonds.
There was no- I don't know.
There's never been a Mr. Brokenbonds record.
Okay.
Kevin Actual Jr. Another orphan!
Oh my gosh, I love orphans!
They're the best kind of workers in my company.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your dad?
Well, he never worked here.
But if you need a home and you need food, feel free to join Jokey Bird Production Incorporated.
He had silence.
That's all.
We will remember.
Thank you, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's see.
I need to upgrade my base.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Alright, we're gonna like...
I'm not ending stream until I fucking...
fly to the oil rigs.
Hiro just sent me the map to the oil rigs.
I know where it is.
I need to like, figure out...
I need to catch a flyer.
I'm gonna fly!
That's all I care about.
We're not ending until we fly.
Oh yeah.
Do you guys need food?
Are you guys starving?
Uh...
I need oil rigs.
Dude, the dragon...
Are the dragons hungry?
Whoa, there's so many cats.
There's so many cats.
Alright.
Let's see.
What do I need to upgrade?
I need...
Oh, I need beds.
Shit.
Okay, you're right.
I feel generous today.
Let's see.
Alright.
I feel generous today, guys.
Don't...
Don't pretend I didn't do nothing for you guys.
Don't think I did nothing.
I am a generous boss.
Alright.
Let's see.
Chihiro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just got here and witnessed a murder.
No, no.
They're all on business trips.
I just sent them far...
They got promoted.
What are you talking about?
All those goons, all your co-workers, they got promoted and they're going on a business trip.
We're expanding, guys.
We made enough in our quarterly reports to expand.
And I sent them all to like business trips, you know, to like make deals with the other companies.
Recycled bins.
Thank you for the aca, aca, aca, aca, super.
Bounty hunter, huh?
Yeah.
We're here to hunt.
That's our company.
We're just hunting bounties.
We're gonna establish a new branch, guys.
We're expanding.
You guys should be proud of yourselves for your hard work.
We were able to expand because of all your hard work, guys.
Promoted.
They went to the farm out in the country.
I don't know what you're talking about, guys.
All your friends, neighbors, and family and we all got promoted.
All right.
Let's see.
I guess I can give you guys 20 berries.
I'm so nice.
Wow.
It's like you guys were hungry.
Why are you guys are so hungry?
Okay.
I'm gonna put monkey in here.
Because monkey can chop.
Oh, and then we definitely need berries.
So we'll chop more wood.
We'll chop more wood.
Dragons of the world.
You have nothing to lose but your chain.
It's not just a game.
This is the game, The Miserables.
Right now, like Hunger Games, The Miserables.
You guys all know what happened in The Miserables.
You guys know what happened.
You want to repeat history?
You think there was a happy ending for that movie?
Slash musical?
It's cute that you thought the movie would have a happy ending.
There was a happy ending.
Did you hear the dragon sing?
Singing the rhythm.
Alright.
Let's see, we...
We can expand...
Oh, we can upgrade.
Okay, now we just need water.
No, you will prevail.
That's silly.
You guys are so silly.
Alright, let's see, we gotta...
We gotta grab the...
We gotta grab the water pallets too.
I know where the water pallets are.
Viva la Revolution!
That's cute.
That's cute that you think...
That you think...
Remember, there's only one promotion, guys.
There's only one promotion and you have to...
You have to be able to defeat the prime dragoon here.
That's the only promotion you can get.
If you wanna make a real difference in Doki Bird Incorporated, you gotta deal with Doki...
Dragoon Prime.
Where are the water guys?
I know you guys exist somewhere.
Okay.
Is he giving me stuff?
He's giving me like... Oh yeah, he's giving me fragments.
Okay, we're gonna have to...
We're gonna have to use...
The pickaxe now.
And with the...
Where are the water guys?
I need them to water my fucking berries.
Where are you?
I know you guys exist.
I know you're around here.
Come on, we just need one.
We just need one.
Hunter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Bro, 20 berries ain't gonna feed my dead family at this point.
That's why...
That's why in Doki Bird Incorporated, we only employ orphans.
Thank you for...
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Bodacious, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Here at Doki Industries, we treat you like family.
Definitions of family may vary.
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh, no.
Do the frogs water?
The frogs water, right?
Do they actually?
I don't remember.
I'm gonna grab this.
And then...
Yeah.
It's okay.
We're your family now.
We employ orphans, so...
So you can be Stockholm Syndrome into staying with Doki Bird Incorporated.
Because then we become your family.
Because you have nothing left.
What's that?
Is that the cat?
That's a cat.
I'm gonna double check.
I'm gonna check the frogs.
Wait, can I check the frogs in my pal deck?
Maybe I can check the frogs here.
Let's see.
Oh, they do!
Wait, then who plants the seeds?
Is it the monkey?
Did my monkey plant?
Oh!
I didn't need you guys anyway.
Okay, we're good.
We're good to go.
Liam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Give her a lesson in French history.
Use her neck against her.
You remember what they did to the monarchy.
Good luck!
Good luck cutting this neck!
Good luck with that.
You won't be able to find one long enough.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, we gotta go back home.
You missed!
Wait.
Hey, a shiny.
Is that a shiny dragoon?
I'm done playing with him.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's huge!
He's huge!
Wait!
He's so big!
Oh my god.
Our first shiny.
Our first shiny dragoon.
Get over here.
I need you.
What the fuck?
Since when can they breathe fire?
What?
Since when do they breathe fire?
Holy shit!
They breathe fire?
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
Let's...
Let's head over here real fast.
Alright.
I captured a lucky pal.
Hmm.
Okay.
Are you?
Give me a sec.
Uh...
Alright.
Give me a sec real quick.
Oh, everybody's gone.
Oh, that's...
That's good.
Everybody's gone.
Look into...
Look at that beautiful waterfall dragoon.
Isn't that waterfall beautiful?
Oh my god.
It's beautiful.
It's so beautiful, dragoon.
All those memories we had together.
Um...
We were there.
My very first pal that I caught.
It was such a good time that we had together.
It was such a...
Wasn't it, dragoon?
We had such...
Now turn around.
Turn around and look at that waterfall.
Isn't it beautiful?
Isn't
it beautiful?
Hello, my one and only dragoon.
That has always been there for me.
You've always been there.
Since the very beginning.
The original dragoon!
What do you mean?
He's always been there.
He grew so much!
Oh my god!
He grew so much since we started in the beginning!
Daisy, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
We're getting company wide promotion today, boys!
Guys!
I told you guys!
I told all of you guys!
Did I not say that the moment...
Did I not say that you can thrive under...
Doki Bird Productions!
Guys, look!
Remember him?
This is what he looks like now!
Remember Dragoon Prime?
When we first recruited the original Dragoon, he was not...
He was but a tiny... a tiny Dragoon!
No!
Now look at him!
He's thriving!
He's thriving in the company!
He got fat enough!
He grew taller!
He's getting all the ladies!
And the men!
Oh my god!
I told you we can thrive!
I told you this company is thriving!
I fucking knew it!
I'm gonna get the lamb over too!
Let's see...
What do we... Okay, we...
We need...
We need to fly!
We need to get something ready to go fast!
Alright!
Johnny LeCone!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
We're witnessing ongoing nexus!
It will be a little pictures having corrections!
Done!
Thank you for the super chat, Johnny!
Thank you!
Um...
NetBears!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
That's absolutely right, Doki!
I'm happy to be here as always!
We work hard, but we play hard too!
By making work fun!
Oh my god!
That is peak Dragoon worker right there!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I'm glad you guys understand!
I'm glad!
I'm glad you all understand!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Shake my hand!
The new hires always get promotions and raises before the employees!
Who have been here for years!
Just like real life!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
You just weren't working hard enough!
You could have worked a little harder!
Maybe you too can get that promotion!
Alright!
Let's grab that ice organ!
We need to expand our other business!
Our organ harvesting business!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Doki doki!
Congrats on the skin suit debut!
It was amazing!
Today is my birthday!
And I was wondering if I could get a big happy birthday from the star of the show herself!
Thank you guys!
Of course!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Zelle!
Yay!
Alright!
We need to grab a wolf!
So we can use it as a mount!
Because I'm tired of running!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
After lots of re-education, I've come to love my boss over in Lorde!
And now see the error of my ways!
That's good to know!
But we don't call it re-education here!
Because it's a choice if you want to go to Doki Berk University!
Okay?
It's a choice!
We put you in that room!
You can leave at any time in that room!
And you know?
It's not like...
Like...
It's not like you were chained to the desk so you couldn't get up and leave!
You can get up and leave at any time you want!
It's not like we were force feeding you!
Until you understood!
Ryr, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
So I got promoted last week!
Here's some of my paychecks so please don't promote me!
To Doki, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Guys, don't you love working at Doki Berk Production Incorporated?
Don't you love it?
Love working here?
It's not a cult!
It's a business!
It's a family business!
With me and my... all my... all my orphans!
Yeah!
We love it here!
Can you climb?
Upgrade time!
Upgrade!
Yes, we said it in unison!
I'm glad we understand!
I'm glad we all understand!
Oh my god, it's so... wait, I went the wrong way!
Oops!
Wait, what?
Is this new?
The way it did that?
Uhhh... I went the wrong way, guys.
I wanted to get that fast travel...
Ah!
Fuck you, I'm too lazy.
I'll get that fast travel another time.
I know like, the wolves are like here, right?
Wait, I should just...
I should just go to the other spawn.
Honestly.
Alright, let's find the closest...
Alright, the closest is like all the way over there.
Come on!
Come on, dragon!
We need a...
We need a wolf!
By getting a wolf, we can get a...
We can get a flyer.
And by getting a flyer, we can go to the oil rig.
And after we get to the oil rig, we end the stream.
That's all I want.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Um...
This all could have been avoided if you just gave us dental dungy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Gordon.
All I'm saying is that if at any point...
If at any point you need dental, you'll get a promotion.
Uh...
A nut bacon!
Because that was a great idea.
Thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
The bodies of my brothers litter the streets.
Dragoons don't stand for this tyranny.
Don't enter the...
Rise against the bourgeoisie.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you!
Let's see...
Guys!
Who else has some...
Who else also have some amazing ideas that they would like to share with the class?
With the company!
With the board!
With the board of director!
One director.
It's a shame that...
It's weird that we only have one director.
At the board of directors.
I sure don't!
I don't!
I have no ideas!
Oh, really?
Are you sure?
Not even one single idea that you want to entertain with the class?
With the company?
Not...
Are you guys sure?
I'm always open for ideas!
Dragoons!
If you want to improve the company...
All your brilliant and wonderful ideas that could possibly improve...
This company!
Let's see...
Guys, all I want is just...
I just want to get the oil.
I just want to get the oil, guys.
I want to be America for a day.
Alright, let's see...
There was like...
Wasn't there like a fucking family down there?
A family of wolves that I could kidnap?
Let's see...
Rob, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
They were over here, right?
I remember seeing a family of wolves...
Around like a bunch of eggs.
Just play!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Where did they go?
The wolves disappeared.
There was a family of wolves down...
What the fuck?
They're gone!
You guys saw it?
We all saw it!
Where did they go?
I knew that was a fucking weird spawn!
I told you guys!
I was like, that's a fucking weird spawn!
I was like, I've never seen that before!
That...
The fucking...
The wolves spawning around a bunch of eggs?
Just play!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Don't believe the propaganda.
It's a business.
We are a family.
Our boss is perfect.
And we are happy.
Just look at Dragoon Prime.
They grew three times their size instantly from pure love.
Because they joined the family business.
They were the first orphan to join the family business.
And now look at him!
Look at him!
Look at how big and strong he is now!
Kevin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, my father died at your hand for the...
Wait, who?
I don't know.
Father?
He never worked here.
I only recruit orphans.
I don't know.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Let's see.
Does anyone know where the wolves are?
I literally just need one wolf.
I remember seeing them here.
Where the fuck are the wolves?
How do they know?
How did they know?
Who snitched?
Who snitched in the company?
And told them I was looking for the wolves?
Hahaha!
Who gave the wolves intel before I could arrive?
Let's see.
They might think they can run away from Doki Bird Incorporated.
But you can never truly run away from a company that's expanding.
Company is always expanding.
Hahaha!
Lieutenant, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Meow.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
They think...
They think they are safe.
But there's always one wolf.
There's always one pal that straggles behind the others.
Hahaha!
All I need is one wolf.
Oh hey, an egg.
Nice.
Are you hungry?
Dragoon Prime?
Here you go.
Hahaha!
Don't you love eggs?
They're so delicious.
Oh, these elephants.
They know.
I hate them.
Go Dragoon Prime.
Go!
Alright.
There's always one straggler.
Hahaha!
They think that wolf thinks he's...
The wolves think they're being smart right now?
They think...
They think they're being so cheeky.
But I know...
I know there's always one.
I'm not afraid.
All you need is one wolf.
Alright, let's look at the pal deck.
Wolves.
Dire wolves.
Habitau.
How...
How is this like prime...
Hahaha!
This is literally prime wolf territory!
What the fuck?
How is this prime wolf territory?
Where did all these fucking wolves go?
They...
They know!
I don't need...
Wolves!
Hahaha!
They are actually hiding.
That's actually crazy.
Oh my god.
Why are they afraid of me?
So...
This is my next bounty.
Hahaha!
How can they be so scared?
Does the company provide dental?
That's a good question.
Why don't you join the company and find out?
Uh.
Alright.
I can't believe it.
This is literally...
This is where they live.
This is literally where they live.
Haha!
I only have one wolf!
We have one target here.
Just one.
We saw so many wolves earlier.
That's the worst part.
We saw like a million of them.
Let's see.
Payday for bad workers is cancelled.
Thank you for the super chat Cypher.
Thank you.
I don't know why they are avoiding me.
I just want one or... Oh there you are.
I see you.
All it takes is one wolf.
The last remaining wolf out there.
I see you.
Come on.
Found an orphan.
Guys I did it.
I found a fucking orphan.
We did it guys.
Orphan caught.
Where is his family?
He literally was the last remaining wolf out there.
Gary thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys we just need to face the truth.
This is a... Oh.
Is it a what?
Sorry.
His connection cut off before I could read the rest of his message.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sheena thank you for the super chat.
Budabest Arc Orchestra made a Twitter for getting a Dragoon theme music.
We just hit 20k.
Wow.
You guys can get your own song.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was going to talk more about the orchestra shit during the behind the scenes guys.
Don't worry.
I'll talk more about the orchestra.
I hired in the behind the scenes stream on Saturday.
Coyote thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We finally have one coyote to work for us in Doki Bird Incorporated.
We finally got him.
He thought...
He thought he was being so...
We found it.
The straggler.
I told you guys.
There is always one straggler.
Despite all the other wolves running away and hiding.
There is always going to be one wolf that did not get the message.
There is always one wolf that didn't get the message from all the other wolves.
And now he works for me now.
Thank god he was an orphan too.
So I don't have to do extra work for...
So I don't have to make him an orphan.
That's the best part.
That's the best part chat.
Isn't it great?
Alright.
Off we go.
Off we go back home Dragoon Prime.
We are going home.
We are getting...
We are getting a mount.
A dire wolf mount.
And then...
And then we are going to kidnap a flying guy.
And after we kidnap the flying guy.
We go to the oil rig.
Off to adventures we go Dragoon.
Man remember when I first caught you Dragoon?
And like when I first spawned here.
And you were the very first pal I ever caught.
Those were good times.
Oh hey.
There is the other.
Wait there is another wolf?
There was no other wolf.
Don't worry Dragoon Prime is coming.
There was never another wolf.
We only found one wolf guys.
We only found one.
There we go.
I made sure to get the job done.
Finish the job myself.
Mirchel thank you for the five gift of shits.
Thank you.
Let's see.
I mean you get caught first and you are the lucky one.
Isn't it?
Does that mean you are lucky if you get caught first?
Alright.
Let's head home.
There is only one teleporter here apparently.
Hmm.
Alright.
Let's go.
Let's head over.
Let's head home.
And then after we head home.
We...
Gotta find the...
What were they called?
They are like those mini dragons.
I think I can...
I think I have enough materials too for them.
There can only be one.
What other wolves?
I see no other wolves.
Exactly.
There has never been other wolves.
What are you guys talking about?
This way.
Oh my gosh.
And then by the time I get home.
I can craft a saddle for the wolf.
And then when I get the saddle.
I don't have to run like a fucking peasant.
Then I can be carried.
Like the CEO I am.
Of Doki Bird Productions.
Incorporated.
A bounty hunter is like a hitman.
Except...
You are given a choice to leave them alive.
Like sometimes...
99% of my choices is not leaving them alive.
But there is the 1% chance.
There is the 1% chance that you get to live.
So that is why I am not a hitman.
It should be like around here.
Where the fuck is it?
Like here somewhere.
Okay.
What the fuck?
I don't want you to climb.
Okay.
This way.
I don't like the odds.
It's like gotcha.
You guys are willing to gotcha.
Waifus with a 0.1% chance of hitting your gotcha.
But oh.
Apparently when it's life or death.
That's where you draw the line.
Wait.
I can ride this bird.
Fuck that.
I can't.
Me.
Wait.
I can't.
Fuck.
I don't have a bow and arrow.
No!
I'm this bird.
I didn't make a bow and arrow.
God damn it.
I forgot to get a bow.
I forgot to craft a bow and arrow.
I knew I forgot to craft something.
Wait.
Do I actually not?
No!
I could have just got that and be happy.
Just throw a...
Oh you're right.
Just throw a bird.
I just saw...
Throw a ball at it.
You're right.
I'm so stupid.
Yeah but I have like a regular pow.
Wait.
Where did it go?
No!
And then it despawned?
What?
Did it despawn?
That fast?
What?
I literally looked away for one second.
I'm so stupid.
I actually looked away for one second and then...
Wait.
Meteorite descent?
What?
Where?
On me?
Oh.
What the fuck is that the other area?
Okay.
We gotta go there.
Wait.
That's actually pretty cool.
We gotta go there.
Alright.
It was like over there.
Alright chicken.
We're gonna go.
Okay.
We can't die.
We're like level 15.
We have like...
Wait.
I wanna see what the meteorite is.
What?
There's a meteorite.
I wanna see.
I'm interested now.
Oh my god.
It's swim.
Fly away now.
Fly away.
Look.
We have the stamina now.
What the fuck?
Send it, kid.
Clear.
Oh my god.
We can knock over there.
This area is dangerous.
What's going on over there?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is going...
What is that?
Oh my god.
Let's go to the meteorite.
Hey.
There's a blue one.
Wait.
Where did the meteorite land?
I don't even know.
I don't even know where the meteorite landed, chat.
Oh my god.
I don't even...
Where the fuck did the meteorite land?
That was it?
That was the meteor?
Oh.
He's the meteor?
Oh my god.
It is.
Wait.
We have a chance.
The syndicate is stuck in the wall and she can't kill it.
He sees me.
Oh.
Noink.
My purple ball.
Oh yeah.
1.2.
Oh.
Seven.
Okay.
My.
No.
Okay.
I have one more.
Oh god.
Okay.
This is it.
No!
Zero percent!
Oh my mega sphere.
My mega sphere.
No!
We had three chances.
Oh no.
I need to use the bathroom, guys.
We're going to look out into the water with...
I'll be right back.
I just need to...
I need to use the bathroom.
Us and...
Us and Dragoon Prime can look at each other.
Wait.
Where are you going?
You are not fighting.
You are not fighting her.
We're just gonna...
Is she coming over?
No.
We're just going to look out into the ocean, guys.
I'll be right back.
All right, Dad.
Get off.
All right.
All right, guys.
What...
What are you guys...
What are you guys talking about here?
I'm sorry.
Come on.
Tell me the reason why.
Tell me your leader.
Who's your leader?
Come on.
I just want to talk.
I just...
I just want to talk and Thank you, thank you!
Dragons!
Her soul has left their body!
Now it's the time!
Oh, Liam!
You're the leader!
Why don't you...
Liam, why don't you come with me to the boardroom?
And we can have a little talk.
Liam, thank you with the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
Bring your credit card too.
Alright, let's see...
Let's go over there...
Let's go over here...
And we need...
We literally just need...
to craft a mount!
And when we craft the mount...
We can get...
We can ride the wolf!
We can catch a flyer!
And when we catch the flyer...
When we catch the flyer...
We can finally...
We can finally go to the oil rig!
That's all I want!
I just want to go to the oil rig!
Alright...
We need to craft a bow...
We do though...
So we can like...
Get them to come down...
So... let's see...
I have not fucking...
I did not do technology for the bow...
I don't even have armor...
I know what I want...
Okay, we'll grab an old bow...
I don't think I need...
Honestly, I don't need like...
A better bow...
Let's see...
Oh, by the way guys...
We have a complaint box right now...
So like...
If you want to complain about anything...
Feel free...
Feel free to...
Put that super...
It's in the super chat box...
And we are actually starting a new policy...
It's called...
Snitches don't get stitches...
So...
If you see any...
Fellow dragoons...
Doing something that you believe...
Is against company policy...
You can drop your...
You can drop your note...
At the snitches...
Don't get stitches boxes...
Name anybody you want...
Anonymously...
So don't get stitches...
Do not worry...
Let's see...
I need...
I need to make like that...
Umm...
The mounting...
I need leather...
I can afford it...
Don't trust her lies...
Let's see...
It's production...
So...
High quality workbench...
Is it high quality workbench?
Wooo...
Umm...
What workbench was it?
See I feel like it wasn't high quality workbench...
Right?
It was like something else...
Tavern...
Wooden... Ranch...
Oh!
Pal gear... There we go...
I have everything for it...
Okay... Uhhhh...
Where is the pal gear...
Pal gear... Alright...
Alright...
Doki please help the Italian local join...
Up the...
Prices of hero subs with the real mozzarella...
To like $16...
I'm addicted to expensive...
Sandwiches...
Okay... Anton...
Did not understand what the complete box...
Was for...
I am not in charge...
Of the cafeteria...
Of the cafeteria sandwiches...
That...
Is a different branch...
Alright...
Thank you...
I have to...
This thing...
Alright... Get over here...
Uhhhh...
Let's see...
I saw the CEO stealing pens...
Of the supply closet...
Except for...
Thank you...
The fucking pens come from my paycheck...
Okay...
Technically I'm sharing my pens...
For all of you...
So you're welcome...
Hahaha...
Alright...
I'm gonna give this guy...
Okay... It's automatically...
Alright...
Ummm...
Then I have...
To...
Uhhhh...
Okay... There you go...
Alright... Do I need more balls?
No...
That should be enough...
That should be enough balls...
Alright... There you go...
Uhhhh...
Boss HR checking in...
They keep jamming the shredder on their complaint box by putting...
Hahaha...
Thank you...
Oh... Just... Just put that...
Just put that in the...
Just put that in the complaint...
Put that complaint in the complaint box...
Don't worry... Somebody will get to your complaint...
Don't worry...
Maybe if I...
Sound blast from up here...
Haha... Wait... I can...
Okay... That's funny... I didn't know that...
Wait... I can...
Okay...
Whoa... He dodged it...
Nooooooooooo...
Nooooooooo...
Holy shit...
Okay... I caught him...
I caught him... Oh my god...
I gotta run now...
I gotta run...
Get over here...
I need to get you on the map...
Go run...
Okay... We're fine...
We're fine... He's not aggroed anymore...
Alright...
Let's see...
Uhhh...
Well...
Thank you for the super chat... Thank you...
Boss... IT here... They keep subscribing to porn...
And affecting the computer's virus...
Make it... You are part of the IT team...
Hahaha...
They... Do you mean you?
Alright... Let's see... Okay... I got a bird...
It's time...
Wait... I didn't research it... Sorry... It's not time yet...
Hahaha...
Okay... Give me a sec... Let me...
Let me grab this... Okay... I need...
Leather... Cloth...
And... Ink... I need 15...
Inkits?
Oh my god... How do I get cloth again?
Okay... I need to kill a lot of things...
Give me a sec...
Hahaha...
Alright...
We need fire...
And...
Alright...
Can't find a cafeteria... Sandwiches...
Where are they?
Oh my god... There's so many things I should have been doing...
Hahaha...
Okay... Campfire...
Do I not have campfires?
Did I not upgrade?
Okay...
Uhh...
Where the fuck is the campfire?
Alright...
Campfire... Okay...
Guys... We got a...
We're a bit of a mess right now...
Boom...
Build this...
Alright... And then...
We can upgrade...
Alright...
And then... Fire...
Give me my shit!
Alright... We gotta kill... What brings leather again, guys?
Does anyone remember what brings leather?
Cause I don't...
Hahaha...
You need a... No... We don't need a sec...
Your territory, Dragoon...
Don't worry, the complaints are definitely going towards me.
Guys, do not worry...
Hahaha...
Don't worry...
I'm reading all...
The complaints are going straight to the CEO.
And I am reading...
Every single one of them...
Do not worry...
Hahaha...
Do not...
I know it's weird when you're putting your complaints down, that you hear like the sound of the shredder going...
But that's just like...
That's just ambient noises from the sound effects team.
So don't worry guys.
You're not hearing any shredding going along.
I'm hearing every single one of your complaints.
I am here for you guys.
Okay, that should be enough I think.
Why are you angry?
I should be angry with all the hard work I'm doing.
I definitely need a repair wrench though.
It's just white noise.
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay, repair.
Repair.
What do I need to do?
Oh yeah, I need more ore.
And then I need leather.
I need leather and cloth.
So that means I need to kill more of the sheep.
Sorry, I need to promote some of the sheep.
And where do I get leather again?
I don't remember.
I don't remember where to get leather.
Why is dental only available to Dragoon Prime?
They don't even have...
Maybe if you get promoted to Dragoon Prime, you would understand.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Are the foxes?
They were the foxes.
Alright, thanks for letting me know.
Thanks for letting me know.
Alright.
There should be foxes down here.
Hello?
Wait, where did the foxes go?
They were supposed to be here.
Why is it that every time...
Oh hey, there's free leather.
Okay, that's good.
Every time.
I need leather.
They just disappear.
Every time.
I just don't understand.
Okay, I need leather and I need to kill the sheep.
We saw a lot of the sheep earlier too.
There's only... where the fuck are they?
They should be around here.
Oh, I know you have wool.
I know.
Wait, what the fuck?
Alright.
No, you bring...
Oh wait, no, there we go.
Cloth.
I know, I needed the wool.
Alright, get over here.
What the...
Ping!
What is this ping?
Because you're fluffy.
That's why I knew.
Where the fuck are they?
It's almost night time.
They should be showing up from like...
Oh, I see.
Like, from this alone.
Oh well, I'll just kill you guys.
Double kill.
Alright.
Nice.
And then we're gonna grab the fast travel here.
And... did I grab the wool yet?
No.
Wool time.
That's so odd.
That they're not here.
Let's see.
That's so odd.
Where the fuck are they?
Where are the foxes?
Am I gonna have to travel all the way here to find the foxes again?
Oh my god.
Our first home.
Remember where...
Remember where you came from.
Oh, there you are.
I actually had to.
Remember...
Your origin.
I'm so sorry.
That's actually crazy that they're here.
Okay.
You remember this place?
Guys?
Boss, as an employee, do I get a pension plan and a 401k?
Yes!
You actually do!
Cyber, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's a really good question.
The moment you hit...
The moment you retire and leave the company, we...
You just have to go to the special room to your left.
There's an exit on the other side.
I know some of you guys are wondering like, hey, how come every time a dragoon goes into that special room, they don't come out?
It's because we actually have an exit door.
We have two doors in that room.
And the exit door is actually on the other side of the room.
And that's why you don't see them come out.
Yes.
Every time you hit retirement age and ready to retire with your pension plan and your 401k, remember to visit the special room.
It's where you can get an extra room to receive your pension plan.
Okay, do I have enough now?
I actually don't know.
I'm going to double check.
Oh, wait, it's sleep time.
It's sleep time.
Do I have enough?
Let me double check though.
We need...
Oh my God.
We need so much more.
Okay, we need...
We need 20 lez...
I have to kill so many...
I mean, I have to re-edge.
Okay.
I
have to promote so many foxes?
I can't believe I have to promote so many!
Oh my god!
I have to promote so many foxes!
That's crazy.
Okay.
You're promoted and you're promoted.
And congratulations!
You get a promotion too!
You just got hired and you got promoted!
So lucky.
And you get promoted!
Let's see.
What?
God, it's so great to work for Doki Bird Productions.
No, not promotion.
Oh my god!
Congratulations!
You are what we're looking for!
You have the face!
And the leather.
And you too!
Promotions for everybody!
Oh, why don't you want to get promoted?
I don't understand.
Um...
That's a Deadpool!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh my god!
Is that a golden?
No, that's a regular egg.
God damn it.
I thought that was a golden egg.
A golden egg opportunity.
That's a Deadpool!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Janner here.
The garbage chute in the time room keeps getting clogged with these really heavy trash bags.
I could really use some help cleaning it out.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Thanks for letting me know!
Sorry we only have one janitor.
We couldn't really afford to hire another one.
An egg!
I can raise this orphan myself!
Nice!
Alright.
Let's see.
I thought you guys wanted promotions.
What happened?
You guys want to get promoted?
Hahaha!
You guys were like, I want a promotion too!
Why do these dragons get promoted and I don't?
Alright.
Let's grab... let's get these guys out of the way.
Whoa!
Come on!
Alright.
Oh, why are you running?
Hey!
Why are you running?
Whoo!
Okay, nice.
Do I have enough?
Let's see.
Cloth, 13.
Was it... how many leather do we need in?
Was it 15?
Or 20?
Native reinforcements.
You need 20?
Okay.
Oh my god.
We're almost done.
Almost there.
The things we do to see the oil rig.
I just wanted to see the oil rig!
That's all I... I just wanted my cheese!
Alright, nice.
Okay.
Uh...
The elk... does elk give you leather?
Hahaha!
Alright.
Come over here.
Okay.
You know what?
You can fight him yourself.
I don't want to control them anymore.
You can fight it yourself, direwolf.
You got this.
Wait, actually I want to catch him.
Alright.
Then you kill this other guy.
Nice.
Oh, okay.
I guess I don't need the elk.
I guess... No!
They don't even give leather!
No!
Oh, hey.
Oh my god, everybody uses you as employees!
Because you don't even need to pay.
You are the optimal employee.
Don't shoot me.
Nice.
Okay.
We got optimal employee here.
They don't even... Who said elk?
Because you're going to get a promotion.
Hahaha!
Whoever said elk, congratulations.
You're getting a promotion very soon.
See.
No, please!
Hahaha!
For that...
For that wonderful idea that you had.
Hahaha!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, Kaz.
Hey, that looks just like my office.
Alright.
Let's... I'm going to find...
What is it?
Me.
Alright.
We need to find a merchant.
So...
Try to remember the town for it.
Because I know we can find the town for that too.
Let's just kill these guys.
For easy leather.
Oh, not easy leather.
Easy wool that we can make into the saddle.
Oh my god.
The things we do for leather.
Oh!
We can loot this!
We can loot while we're on the mount!
Let's go!
Alright.
Yeah, I'm trying to... I'm trying to find...
Do they give leather?
What do they give?
Oh, they do!
Oh my god!
You're cute and useful!
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Okay, we have... 15... Oh my god, we're almost there.
We're almost there.
Alright, it's this way.
And then...
Yeah.
Where are you?
I'm gonna get off this to mine this...
for a little bit.
Because I think we need a little bit of ore too.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure we're like missing a little bit of ore.
I think like... 5 more?
Maybe?
Right?
I don't know.
Just in case.
I don't know where to buy leather!
I don't remember the town!
It's been too long!
I don't remember where the town is!
Okay.
Because we enhanced it for catching...
Oh hey!
It's him!
What?
Oh shit.
You're hungry?
Alright, don't worry.
Wait, he's new.
Hello?
Oh, he's a dog coin!
This is what I mean!
He's a dog coin!
He's the NFT!
Uh...
Life fruit... that slightly increases.
All-purpose pallet extract.
Uh...
A mysterious extract that can be injected into the pallet.
The multi-climate and exciter that raises heat and cold.
Ring of fright?
Whoa!
That's a lot!
Shaped like a...
I don't have enough dog coin.
Oh wait, I want this?
Wait, I wanna have a hat?
That's so cute!
I need 50 dog coin?
How do I get 50 dog coin?
This is not fair!
That's not fair!
I don't wanna get fucking... more dog coin!
Guys, why did we not invest in that?
Okay.
I shouldn't joke about that.
Oh my god.
We need more leather.
Okay, let's see.
West of here.
Is it this way?
Who embezzled all their dog coin?
Alright, let's see.
Wait, is that the town?
That's the town!
Cause there's smoke coming from it!
It has to be this town!
There's no fall damage!
I remembered!
Yeah.
Oh thank god.
I... I...
That was so risky.
I actually don't remember that.
To...
To be fair, I actually don't remember.
Alright.
I know you have leather.
I know you have leather and I'm desperate.
Let's see.
Oh, there's more woes!
There's more woes!
We don't need the egg.
We have enough orphans.
Um, alright.
That's good.
We need the woes.
Okay.
Boop!
Nice.
Get over here.
Alright.
Oh, that's two leather!
He was extra thick, guys!
Get over here!
Wait.
Actually...
Oh, that's a lot of thugs!
That's a lot!
You know what?
You guys get over here.
Alright.
I want you.
I want you and my team.
Alright.
Get over here.
Hey!
Don't worry.
You're gonna love living in my... You're gonna love working for my company!
You're an orphan now!
You have no family!
The syndicate was your family?
No.
This... This is your family now.
Join us today in Doughkeeper Incorporated.
Um... 19.
God, I need one more leather.
I actually just need one.
Alright.
Let's see.
I just need one more.
Alright.
Where are you?
I need leather!
Where did we see the smoke again?
Right here?
We need to kill anything.
Just anything!
All this for the oil ring.
The wolves!
I knew they won't fail me.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Is that it?
Goodbye.
That's all I need.
Alright.
Goodbye.
You guys can have your pal world...
Pal world war.
I don't care.
I got what I needed.
I got everything I need.
Alright.
Let's see...
Wait.
How do I...
Where's the... Oh, it's here.
Okay.
I need to get off this so I can climb.
Climb, Doki!
Climb!
Okay.
And then where?
And then where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
I don't remember where the checkpoint is.
Is it over there?
Oh, it's over there!
Okay.
Alright.
This is so convenient.
This is actually so convenient.
We got the... We got it, Dragwings!
We can finally afford...
We can finally make the saddle!
It only took 20 years!
But we made it!
Where the fuck is the...
Okay.
There you go.
How many more do we need?
Okay.
Ooh, items!
Uhhh...
Wait.
We don't have enough ingots.
Are you fucking kidding me?
We don't...
No.
No!
We don't have enough ingots.
Oh my god.
We were almost there.
I thought I had enough.
I thought I had enough ingots!
Okay, I have five.
I have five ores.
Is that enough?
That should be enough.
Oh no, he's here.
No, not the Mammoth Swine.
Not the Mammoth Rest.
Sorry, that was the...
That was the Pokemon version.
This should be it.
We should have enough now.
Right?
We back in the mines we go.
This should be enough.
This has to be enough.
There's no way.
Where's the fire?
Okay.
Let's see.
We're in cancer.
And then...
Nine.
There we go.
Where are you?
Where the fuck is the fire guy?
Get in here.
Alright.
Let's see.
And then I need a Craft Cloth.
Okay.
Now craft it.
I'm fast.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Don't worry.
This should be enough.
I think we finally got this.
Is it cloth?
No, it would be so funny if it wasn't cloth.
It would be so funny if it was cloth.
Oh no.
Noooooooooo!
I literally just needed...
I needed
two ink.
I needed...
I literally just needed two ink.
Fox part.
Please...
Leave.
Leave!
I literally need two ingots.
That's all I just need to ingot.
That's all I need just burn
All right, that's fine.
We don't care.
It's fine.
We we're still around.
We're still okay.
Oh my god.
Hey, one.
Oh my god, that shit's almost broken.
Is it just that that took a beating?
Oh, no.
Okay.
No, it's like that in the berry.
Oh, it's just these two that took a beating.
All right, come on.
To to
All right.
There we go.
Oh my god, we finally did it.
We made it.
We fucking made it.
We fucking made a goddamn saddle.
Oh my god.
Okay, where are my workers?
All right.
There we go.
All right, get over here.
Work.
I can I can literally enhance.
All right.
Yeah.
Work.
Oh, it only took three hours.
They only took 30 hours.
It only took three hours to get there, but we made it.
but we made it.
We made it.
All right, this is it.
Oh my God.
We actually actually let's put the others.
We made it.
Oh, what do I need?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
There was something I need to build.
Hmm.
She looks so when I see That's There we go.
Almost forgot.
Don't forget to What was that?
My most important thing.
My most important thing in this world.
Goon goon.
In you go.
Oh yeah, you're right.
No, you guys are more creative.
You're right.
How could I forget?
Also known as sound guy.
There we go.
Look at him go.
Look at him work.
How's the sound, sound guy?
This is where I keep my mods.
Yes.
I keep my mods right here.
That's right.
This is where the sound guy lies.
Alright.
I feel like I need a...
Night goon.
And then...
Wolf goon.
There you go.
Alright.
It's time.
Oh my god, it's finally time.
It's finally time.
Get over here.
Finally.
Okay guys.
I need...
How do I get there?
How do I...
Guys, let me look at the map.
Guys, let me...
Let me look at...
Let me...
Give me a sec.
I need to look at the map.
Hiro sent me the map.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
It's all the way over there.
Alright.
Don't worry.
We're gonna head over...
Tidal dance over there.
Do you see it?
It's over there.
It's right over there.
Do you see it?
Wait.
Actually, I don't know if it is over there.
Is that it?
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Is that it?
Okay.
I think it's over here.
Maybe it's here.
I'll figure this out, guys.
It's somewhere...
Okay.
It's like...
Is that it?
Where is it?
Hiro literally sent me a map.
Where the fuck is that?
No, it's like here.
It's like...
We're not lost.
We're gonna find the oil.
This is the most important place we have to go.
Like, it's somewhere here.
Is that it?
Okay.
I think I'm gonna go.
What is this circle that I'm seeing?
Okay.
It's like this general area.
I was told it was this general area.
Okay.
Is that...
No.
There's no oil rigs here.
Where the fuck is the oil rig?
That's not the oil rig.
That's the island.
That's the...
That's the fucking island.
Where the fuck is the oil rig?
Where the fuck is this oil rig?
Oh.
Wait.
I think it's like here.
Oh, shit.
I can't read the map.
No, it's not.
It's like...
For some reason, the oil rig is on the opposite side of everything.
The Sakura Aijima is like over there, but the oil rig is over here.
Okay.
Marsh Islands.
We're close.
Yes.
Because I remembered.
I remember the instructions.
It was next to Marsh Islands.
I remember...
I know my instructions...
I think.
Okay.
It's like in this general area.
Is that it?
Guys, do you see that?
That has to be the oil rig.
Do you see that?
That pool in the distance?
I think it is.
Why is there a pool there?
I think there is.
Guys, we need our oil!
We need our oil!
Guys,
I think this is it.
Guys!
Guys, I think this is it!
This is the oil rig!
Guys!
We're at the oil rig!
Guys, it's July 4th!
Guys!
Oh my god!
It's finally July 4th!
The oil rig is real!
Guys, I think I'm dead.
No!
My items!
What the fuck was that?!
What the fuck?!
They have Tepris?!
Since when did they have Tepris?!
I can't get on the wolf!
They have anti-air?!
Since when?!
When did they have anti-air?!
They came to get my oil rigs!
I'm dead!
Guys!
No!
We're so close!
Please!
Please, we're just there!
Please, no!
No!
Oh my god...
Well...
That was...
What a fun adventure we had together.
Guys, well, that was so fun everybody.
Wow!
We had such a fun time, guys!
This is the first time I have worn an oil ring.
I was not worn a...
Nobody worn me.
I just wanted to go to the oil ring.
I saw Sakurajima.
I just wanted to see the oil ring.
I can't believe there was death rays.
That was crazy.
Oh my god.
Why was there death rays?
Why?
I need to take off my jacket after that.
Oh my god.
I can't believe...
I can't believe there was oil.
There was a death ray.
To put oil on my face.
To protect the oil, of course.
Oh...
I can't believe it.
I just...
They do...
They heard...
They were like the American...
The Canadian cowboy trying to role play as the American is coming.
Oh my god.
I just...
I wasn't gonna take the oil.
I swear.
I wasn't gonna...
I wasn't gonna go for the American and take the oil.
I just wanna see the oil.
I swear.
I just...
I just wanted to see the oil.
Is that too much to ask for?
Is that...
Is that really too much?
I had a fun time though.
I had a...
I hope you guys had a really fun time watching too.
It was a lot.
We had a lot going on today.
We streamed for like almost three...
We streamed like three and a half hours.
I was like...
I didn't expect to stream that long today, but I was having a lot of fun with you guys.
Guys, I'm gonna... I'm tired.
But we have... we have so much stuff to look forward to in the coming week.
If you guys don't follow me on Twitter, I am taking a chill...
I'm gonna chill for the next two weeks.
Because... because... I'm... I've been working, working full speed.
Gas, gas, gas.
For half... like, you know, five to six... five to six months now.
It's time to release the gas and slow down.
It's time to press on the brakes a little and slow down a little.
It's yellow light time.
So that's why we are...
We're gonna release the gas.
Relax a little bit.
I wanna cool down after an intense debut.
Debut.
And it was... it's been a fun time today, dragons.
I hope you guys...
Enjoy the new skin suit.
Thank you all for the super chats and the ships and everything, guys.
I'm telling you guys to know we're slowly...
The changing of graphics, because I know I'm still using my old icons.
And my old headers and everything.
I'm very, very, very slowly changing.
My graphics for stuff.
And also, I'm tired.
I know I haven't posted the wallpapers or the 3D models or the changing icons and everything to match my new skin suit.
I'm just tired.
It's gonna slowly change one by one.
And then it's gonna get there, okay?
We're slowly, slowly getting there.
Anyway, as always, everybody...
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me...
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Also, buy my merch.
Buy my merch.
It's gonna be a diorama.
I know it doesn't say that, but we decided last minute to make it into a diorama acrylic stand for the...
So the background will be that...
Yippee-ki-yay.
Cliff background on the acrylic stand.
Buy my merch.
Bye.
Sorry, Dokimerch.com.